So. Jetzt geht's. Jetzt probieren wir's nochmal. Was? Alter! Ich krieg Modern Warfare. Was, was, was geht hier ab? Was macht das Game mit meinem Rechner, ey?
Was macht das Game mit meinem Rechner?
Mal als Game Capture. Mal als Game Capture.
Jetzt Game gecaptured. Okay, vielleicht geht es mit Game Capture besser.
Wir droppen Frames, oder? Okay, wir probieren es jetzt mal aus. Sagt mir, ob es ruckelt.
Bis jetzt ist es okay, ne?
Bis jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
Wir droppen auch nichts. Okay.
Kokona, weiter geht's.
Singleplayer. Wir droppen nichts. Okay, wir droppen keine Frames. Sehr gut. Keine Frames. Wo muss ich hin?
Hier. Ich bin voll falsch gelaufen. Gut, also zurück zur Story. Wir stellzen uns durch irgendeine verlassene russische Basis, die wir vorher weggebashed haben.
Was, man kann Pixel zählen? Ich stream mit 6.900 Bitrate.
Ist das echt so pixelig? Keine Güte.
Also Call of Duty ist echt immer mega anstrengend zu streamen.
Ja, gut. Das ist jetzt, weil es dunkel ist. Ich stream nicht mehr über Grafikkarte. Ich stream wieder mit CPU. Aber vielleicht liegt das an der Bitrate.
Vielleicht stelle ich es lieber wieder auf Very Fast. Weiß jemand, ob man das on the fly umstellen kann in OBS und es funktioniert, ohne stream neu zu starten?
Ich gucke gerade mal auf meine Vorschau.
Weiß ich, ob das jetzt wirklich viel besser ist.
Warum 48? Ja, weil das Game laggt, wenn ich mit 60 FPS streame. Okay, auf geht's.
Hoffentlich ist das jetzt okay.
Weil in dunklen Teilen, ja gut, dunkel ist immer so ein Wunderpunkt bei ganzen Streaming-Geschichten.
Okay, also wir machen das jetzt noch einmal, Leute. Ich lade jetzt vom letzten Checkpoint. Ich starte jetzt nochmal den Stream neu und dann gucken wir, ob es funktioniert.
Surprise hat die Grafik weggeraucht. Ich meine, 6.900 Kilo, also besser, mehr Quali geht eigentlich nicht. Die nicht neu starten. Ja, aber kann man jetzt mitleben oder nicht?
Ich meine, das in dunklen Bereichen des Pixels ist normal. Wir warten mal, bis es hell wird.
Oh, jetzt kommt Nachtsicht Gerätstell. Jetzt ist es ja wahrscheinlich voll abartig. Ich muss mir das jetzt mal in der Vorschau angucken. Das Pixelt wahrscheinlich wie Hölle jetzt.
Watsch, so schlimm ist das doch gar nicht.
Vollkommen okay, wie das ausschaut. Das sieht bei keinem Stream besser aus in solchen Szenen. Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung, sieht das aus. Ich sehe es hier gerade bei mir in der Vorschau.
Das sieht sogar richtig gut aus.
Oh, da hat es gestellts.
Gleich mal rein sliding hier. Huge Aim am Start.
Ach nee, entgegen jedem anderen Game ist ja ein Call of Duty E Nahkampf und F benutzen.
Wisst ihr was Leute, das ändern wir jetzt gleich mal.
Wo?
Ach hier.
Und Nahkampf?
Ja, Nahkampf F. Genau, so passt.
Ich muss hier Lichtschalter anmachen.
Spetsnaz ist am Start.
Singleplayer, keck weh.
Wo ist eigentlich Price am Start? Price ist gar nicht dabei.
Fick mafs.
Nee, ich glaube das sind unsere. Ach das sind unsere.
Wo genau sind die jetzt hergekommen?
Ich muss mal gerade mein Programm wieder starten, mit dem ich Bildchen einplanten kann. Sonst kann ich nicht mal Kokona einplanten.
Das ist fatal.
Und jetzt wieder anfängt zu laggen, ne? Da legts halt Anti-Cheat.
Kokona einplanten geht, dann ist alles gut.
Einsteigen.
Ach nee.
Das macht Pause, wenn ich Kokona Einblendung mache. Nö, machts nicht.
Autsch. Nein, kein Raytracing, kein RTX On. Ich hab hier nur ne 1080. Nur, nur ne 1080 GE.
Wir werden gebashed. Geht aber nicht.
Was, ihr seht nichts? Warum seht ihr nichts?
Nee, ich hab diesmal keine 2080 GE gekriegt. Danke für die ganzen Subs, Leute. Den haben wir hier. Moment Leute, ich muss mal kurz was zur Story sagen.
Leute, kann das sein? Oh nee, Storytime. Muss jetzt ruhig sein.
Oh, was jetzt?
Was jetzt? Whoa. Whoa. Fall of Duty, please. Das ruckelt bei mir jetzt übrigens auch.
Die Massenvernichtungswaffen wieder am Start.
Was? Was passiert überhaupt? Sie haben bei den Russen irgendwelches Massenvernichtungsgas gefunden oder so.
Und Price basht die Leute. Und jetzt sind wir in London.
Okay, ich blick hier noch nicht so ganz durch, aber das kommt vielleicht noch. Das sieht irgendwie voll französisch aus, oder?
Und er auch. Irgendwie sehen die voll französisch aus. Ich kann es nicht beschreiben warum, aber irgendwie kauen die nach Frankreich aus. Und dabei sind wir in London.
Okay, die fahren da einfach so vorbei. Big Brain.
Okay, was jetzt?
Okay, erstmal alles fressen.
Okay, die Terrorists machen das, was die Terrorists am besten können. Eine Runde Anele-Time.
Das ist auch schon so ein bisschen Klischee, oder? So Terrorist am Start. Oh nein, was ist BÄÄM? Erstmal sich in die Luft sprengen.
Es können Terroristen nichts anderes als sich in die Luft sprengen. Okay, man muss ja mal sagen, im Verhältnismittel wahrscheinlich können Terroristen wirklich viel anderes als sich in die Luft sprengen.
Andere in die Luft sprengen.
Und das wirkt im Game wirklich so gut aus. Das sieht relativ gut aus, ja.
Oh, oh. Das ist einer von mir. Oh, da ist er.
Die Terrorists brauchen eine ordentliche Waffe.
Oh, das war ein Polizist.
Suicide Bomber. Silence.
Oh, ich meine meine Waffe ist leer. Ich brauche Ammo. Ammo.
Ammo. Wo ist der Ammo?
Ammo. Ja.
Beste.
Ich will nur noch die roten Tigerstreifen, dann kann nichts mehr schief gehen.
Roten Tigerstreifen.
Weg.
Autsch.
Nochmal Suicide Bombers.
Die Inszenierung ist cool. Gefällt mir. Wenn auch ein bisschen vorhersehbar alles, aber okay.
Wir gucken uns mal ein bisschen um, ob sie sich Mühe gegeben haben.
Wir schauen uns mal an, ob sie sich Mühe gegeben haben. Wir gucken uns mal ein bisschen um.
What the hell? Was jetzt?
Ich dachte, die Mission geht im Haus weiter, aber gut.
Ohne AK.
Aha, hier geht es nicht weiter.
Okay, für Call of Duty Verhältnisse sind das hier schon tatsächlich relativ offene.
Okay, hier haben wir das übliche. Hier haben wir das übliche Call of Duty. Sie verlassen das Schlachtfeld.
Das ist die falsche Flagge. In Call of Duty ist prinzipiell eigentlich nur die US-Flagge erlaubt.
Für mehr Kona.
Es sieht aber gut aus. Okay, wir gucken uns mal kurz um, wie das so ausschaut.
Hier? Wahrscheinlich dürfen wir nicht in Häuser rein. Das hätte mich jetzt gewundert.
Hier dürfen wir mit Sicherheit auch nicht drüber. Okay.
Hier sollen wir, glaube ich, lang. Ich glaube, hier sollen wir lang, oder?
Auf was schießt er da eigentlich?
Alles okay?
Ich kann verstehen, dass in London der Verkehr schon etwas ätzend ist.
Ich habe ja gehört, dass diese Ringstraße, die London umgibt, eines der schlimmsten Straßen auf der Welt sein soll.
Aber dass er jetzt die Ampel da irgendwie wegbashing muss, weiß ich auch nicht.
War da oben ein Sniper-Dude drin? Wow, da war ein Sniper-Dude drin.
Aha.
Warum du bei mir Sport-Ätzend bekommst? Weil es Sport ist.
Kann man die Schüte runterschießen? Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren, ob man die Schüte...
Kann man nicht. Ich will einfach mal gucken, ob die sich Mühe gegeben haben mit der Map, bevor wir mit der Mission weiter machen.
Einfach mal schauen.
Excellent. Five-Hand-Musik.
Excellent.
Five-Hand-Wine.
Wo...
Der ist da schön gescriptet, gespawnt. My kind of music. Genau. Exquisite. Exquisite.
Okay, machen wir die Mission weiter. Also, für Call of Duty-Verhältnis ist das hier schon eigentlich eine riesen Map.
Und architekturtechnisch ist es auch ganz...
Ganz nett, ja. Kann man Lampen kaputt machen?
Haben sie nicht irgendwo im Trailer gezeigt, man kann Lampen kaputt machen?
Okay, auf geht's. Jetzt machen wir die Mission mal weiter.
Erstmal Track-Moven.
Ich denke...
Da ist er.
Der Price ist heiß. Da ist er.
Der Pausbacken-Price.
Da kommt Price. Der ist ein bisschen schneller um die Ecke.
Guck mal, der hat einen.
Ich... Ich würde ja mal gerne probieren, was passiert, wenn ich da drauf schieße.
Wir probieren das mal kurz.
Okay, es explodiert tatsächlich.
Es explodiert tatsächlich.
Da haben sie drauf geachtet.
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Subs. Also, wann haben wir denn jetzt alles gekriegt?
Headpin, Nexo, KK, Ultimate Power, Twitcher, Tommy Lee, Besten.
Oh, ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt Bomb-Defuse machen.
Fresh-Saw-0, Dankeschön.
Okay, ich darf keine Twitch-Prime-Ansagen machen.
Okay, Leute, gleich. Ich muss jetzt erstmal Story weitermachen, ja?
Fresh-Saw-Independent-Astoria, Dankeschön. Twitch-Prime, tut.
Das ist ein Schloss.
Handy abreißen.
Mach halt das Handy ab.
Okay.
Yep.
Inszeniert ist das echt nice. Kann ich nix sagen.
Aber, ich mein, er hätte auch einfach das Handy abreißen können, ne?
Weil er hätte das Ding kein Zünder mehr gehabt.
Ja, das wäre zu Big Brain gewesen, glaube ich.
Bin ich das?
Bin ich? Aber man sieht mal, wie man aussieht. Das ist doch gut.
Alexander.
Genau.
Okay, also sie sind angepisst, weil sie nichts, nicht machen können, was sie wollen.
Ich sehe keinen Mauszeiger in dem Katium.
Wo hat's he gestanden?
Ja, ich mach den Mauszeiger weg.
Natürlich, das würden die nie machen.
Okay.
Die Zwischensequenzen sehen echt gut aus.
Urzikistan. Gibt's das?
Gibt es Urzikistan?
Ach, mir fällt jetzt auf, was die Farah heißt.
Farah Origin Story.
Oh je, wenn ich Farah jetzt zu sehr auf den Hinterkopf gucke, regen sich die Feministen über das Game auf.
Okay, ich soll mich verkleiden.
Erstmal so eine schöne Terroristenmaske aufziehen.
Ich glaube, ich sollte nicht schießen, oder?
Ich glaube, ich sollte nicht schießen, kann das sein?
Gucken Sie, die Russen sind so blöd und lassen sich flaschen.
Okay, die Russen zacken.
Gib mal die AK her.
Okay, wir concealn das Weapon. Jetzt ist es secret.
Also wir haben jetzt erstmal 10 Russen umgebracht, aber jetzt wird es secret. Das merkt bestimmt auch keiner mehr jetzt, nachdem ich erstmal 10 Stück gekildet habe.
Okay, Farah, zeig mir, wo es lang geht.
Weiß jemand, ob das Game irgendwelche Secrets im Singleplayer hat in Form von Marken, die man sammeln muss, Audiologs, die man sammeln kann, Abzeichen, Waffen oder so?
Dann kann man einfach Main... Okay, man kann einfach Mainweg langstellen.
Das ist Kot.
Ja.
Okay, keine so gute Idee.
Das geht ja nicht, ja.
Ich glaube, die Story möchte, dass ich die nicht kille, oder? Die Story möchte, dass ich hier Steine nehme.
Und dann mit dem Stein hier lang stelle sie.
Das hat jetzt keiner gemerkt, dass sie den grad Ballistik knifed hat across the map.
Geht ab.
Only use me knife, Farah.
Und ich muss... Was für Knopfwaffe verstecken?
Das ist ein Dual mit dem Friseur. Der Friseur interessiert sich leider nicht mehr dafür.
Kaufen oder nicht, weiß ich noch nicht. Ich hab grad erst angefangen.
Suppressor? Ach komm, wir brauchen keinen Suppressor.
Guck mal, das sind... Was sind das? Wir brauchen noch keinen Suppressor. Guck dir mal an, das sind die übelsten Kacknubs.
Hä?
What? Oh!
Okay. Okay, vielleicht sollten wir uns da reinholen.
Okay, Suppressor.
Oilfilter?
Nein, das ist nicht veteran. Das ist normal. Aber die Story möchte nicht, dass ich hier schieße. Deswegen bin ich wahrscheinlich so schnell down.
Ähm... Oilfilter, Oilfilter.
Ich kann keinen Kirillisch.
Ich bin in der Garage. Hier.
Alter.
Wie das passt, hä? Wie das passt.
Da hat es sich doch endlich mal gelohnt, die ganzen Life-Hack-Videos auf YouTube zu gucken.
Die Ölsmeckei war, ja. Fehlt bloß das Taschenwasser. Wahrscheinlich hat er Life-Hack. Top 10 Life-Hack.
Und da wird es bestimmt gezeigt, wie das funktioniert.
Der ist schon tot. Du musst den nicht noch mehr killen.
Overkill.
Okay, ähm... Wir haben eine AK-47. Ich glaube, das ist...
Oh, guck dir mal. Das war die OP-Waffe. Wo ist die Waffe hin?
Hier. Das war die OP-Waffe aus MW3. Schaut mal. Kennt ihr die noch?
Das ist die übelste. Das war diese krass OP-Waffe aus MW3.
Die Dildo-Gun, genau.
Schnell.
Ach, zum Glück liegt das hinterm Sofa versteckt.
Interessant, dass die Pistole mit so einem draufgeflatschten Ölfilter auf einmal den Ultra-Silencer drauf hatte.
Man muss halt kreativ sein.
Was war diese Bastelsendung? Die Sendung mit der Maus war? Wir erklären euch, wie es ist. Es gab doch eine Sendung, wo die immer gebastelt haben.
Okay, erst mal random ein paar Leute erhängen.
Stellst mich da mal vorbei.
Ob man die Leute retten kann?
Schnell kann man nicht retten.
Das ist Story. Es geht nicht, dass man die Leute retten kann.
Jetzt?
Also ich weiß, ich soll weiter. Mal gucken, ob hier noch was passiert. Wir schauen mal, wie sehr sie sich Mühe gegeben haben.
Der Dude, der kreiselt einfach nur weiter jetzt.
Da war kein Budget mehr für mehr Dialog da.
Budget fertig.
Ich laufe nicht in die Mitte. Wenn ich in die Mitte laufe, dann bashen die mich.
Auf Fahrer.
Ich mach das jetzt absichtlich.
Also mir ist klar, dass ich jetzt beim Fahrer die Treppe hoch soll. Aber ich probiere mal, was passiert, wenn ich vor anders lang gehe.
Okay, nichts. Das wundert mich. Ich hätte jetzt Call of Duty mäßig erwartet, sie verlassen das Kampfgebiet oder sowas.
Hey Guards, was geht?
No Scope aus der Hüfte.
Okay, der No Scope aus der Hüfte ist nicht so clever. Ich glaube, ich soll das schon ordentlich machen.
Okay.
Muss ich eigentlich hin?
Guck mal, da oben muss ich hin.
Mit Scope aus der Hüfte, klar.
Dann müssen wir jetzt den Helistels machen hier.
Wo spielt das Ganze? In Uzbekistan oder so?
Das Land gibt es nicht. Das Land ist wahrscheinlich an ein russisches Grenzland angelehnt.
Sowas zwischen Russland und, keine Ahnung, da wo Uzbekistan ist oder so heute.
Oh, guck mal.
Ein ACOG.
Nee, der hat noch einen Red-Dot.
Peter!
Jack!
Jetzt kommt der Helistels.
Ach nee, wir sprengen den Heli in die Luft, okay.
PP-Hands, ja Leute.
Wenn es euch dann besser geht, Chat, wenn es euch besser geht, einmal F für den Hund.
Beast Mode, auf und an da außen, Dankeschön.
Aber sowas ist der Twitch-Chat immer dabei, ne?
Da geht's weiter.
Achtung, wir machen jetzt Slide-Action hier.
Nice.
Jetzt.
Oh!
Na, das ist ja aber mal ein geiler Ölfilter, dass die auf jegliche Waffe allen sein, als er draufpasst.
Nicht schlecht.
Oh!
Da waren ja Wachen.
Wollen wir hier? Zeit?
Moment, das war doch gerade der Pilot, der mir da von hinten entgegengekommen ist.
Ist der hier runtergefallen?
Ich höre übrigens Schritte, ich höre Schritte.
Schritte.
Ich höre Schritte da unten.
Kann man von hier oben noch ein paar Russen daschen oder so?
Da klitscht irgendwas durch.
Ah, das ist Fahrer, der da unten lang rennt.
Das waren die Schritte von Fahrer.
Hätte ich mal das Jetpack.
Okay, das war schlecht, gebe ich zu.
Wann kommt eigentlich das Overwatch, das Overwatch-Cod-Crossover?
Ich bin doch schon da.
Schon am Start.
Okay.
Blow it up.
Hatte das irgendeinen Zünder dran?
Auf geht's, Russen-Bash.
Da schießen wir jetzt natürlich nicht drauf, wir sind ja die Guten.
No Happy Meal for you, dankeschön, vier Monate in Folge, krasser Scheiße.
Das sieht natürlich auch keiner, ne?
Fahrer schon wieder auf den Hinterkopf.
Was sollen die Feministen hier von dem Stream denken?
Das ist Family-freundlicher Stream, ich darf jetzt, das geht nicht.
So, geht das hier?
Okay, jetzt kann ich.
F***, wo ist sie hin?
Ah, da vorne.
Einmal nicht hingeguckt, schon ist sie weg.
Oh, oh.
Hallo, kannst du mal ein bisschen schneller rennen, krasser Elite-Soldat?
Das Rebellen-Grill rennt doppelt so schnell wie Alex.
Dabei ist Alex hier einer der besten, der besten von den besten.
Übrigens, Doppelsprint geht in der Kampagne irgendwie nicht, merke ich gerade.
Und wo sind die Russen von vorne?
Die Russen kommen bekanntlich immer nur von einer Seite.
Ihr wollt mir doch jetzt nicht erzählen, dass sie mich nicht finden.
Das erinnert mich an die Sniper-Mission.
Der läuft nämlich nicht drüber.
Nee, der läuft an mir vorbei, habe ich nochmal Glück, ja.
Weißt ihr was?
Oh, wir machen jetzt den krassesten Bash aller Zeiten.
Ah, weggesprayt.
Schon haben wir Fahrer voll beeindruckt mit unserem krassen Quick-Spray.
Wo ist denn Fahrer jetzt schon wieder hin?
Okay, wir probieren jetzt mal, ob man schneller sprintet.
Ich finde das echt krass, dass das Rebellen-Grill doppelt so schnell sprintet,
wie der übelste Elite-Soldat.
Oh nee, jetzt habe ich voll auf Fahrer geballert.
Direkt.
Das war wahrscheinlich auch nicht so gedacht.
Jetzt testen wir mal, wie viel Mühe sie sich gegeben haben.
Okay, ein bisschen.
Keine Mühe, doch ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen Mühe gegeben, keine Mühe gegeben.
Wenig Mühe gegeben.
Aber ansonsten, also von der Beleuchtung her finde ich das ganz hübsch.
Geht natürlich nicht.
Ist das Pair-to-Pair-Verbindung oder Server?
Angeblich alle Server.
Ist die jetzt hoch oder runter hier?
Clara am Start.
Oh, jetzt müssen wir in den Tunnel stelsen.
Wir sind der krasse Styler aus den USA.
Wir klettern nicht einfach nur die Treppe runter, wir sliden die Treppe runter.
Geht das?
Wir müssen Fahrer beeindrucken.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Oh nee, man muss mit Animationen.
Soll ich die Ping-Anzeige anmachen?
Die Harris wahrscheinlich nicht.
Okay, wir nehmen jetzt mit vier Leuten die russische Basis ein, easy.
Die richtige Ausrüstung mit vier Leuten, russische Basis, kein Problem.
Oh, was ist das für ein fettes Teil?
Das ist aber irgendwie ein bisschen MonkaS mit dem Ding hier durchs Haus zu laufen, oder?
Guck mal, wo der hingeht.
Ach, ich darf nicht hinterher.
Ach, was haben wir da?
Haben wir noch mehr Waffen?
Das?
K98, ein bisschen mehr zweiter Weltkriegsflare.
Komm, eine AK47 und ein K98.
Bessere Kombi gehen doch ein, ich gar nicht.
Es gibt Thronenstells.
Ah nee, RC-Planes, okay, Thronenstells.
So, so, rechte Maustaste macht nichts.
Oh, linke Maustaste gibt Gas, jawoll.
Was die Rebellen in Uzikistan alles haben, hä?
Die Russen scheinen wieder mal nicht die Hellsten zu sein.
Der Rüpel, Stufe 1, vier Monate, Dankeschön, nice.
Ricky OMFG, Dankeschön, Void Danny ist auch am Start, Tommy Lee 070, Bastion Prime 1996,
Beast Mode, Game SICK und ich glaube Independent Astoria hatten wir schon.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs.
Big brain subs, high IQ, soll ich dazu machen.
Jetzt holen wir erstmal eine gute K98 raus und wäschen die Russen.
Man kann nicht Quickscope mit der K98, so kann ich nicht arbeiten.
Man kann nicht Quickscope, so kann ich nicht arbeiten, Leute.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Jawoll.
Ja, ja, so ist der.
Jetzt werden die Russen gebashed.
Weiß jemand, ob FFA noch kommt?
Wie, es gibt kein Freefall? Ernsthaft jetzt?
Pass auf jetzt.
Doch, Server sind überlassen. Ah ja.
Oh, das ist... What?
MP5, ich brauche eine MP5, MP5, gib.
MP5, jawoll, beste.
Jetzt haben wir gewonnen.
Jetzt kann eigentlich nichts mehr passieren, wenn wir eine MP5 am Start haben.
K98, MP5.
Komplettes deutsches Waffenasenal, was im Game drinne ist, weiß nicht, ob es noch mehr gibt.
Mit der AUG hätten wir noch ein bisschen Österreich reinfliegen können.
AUG, was? Warte mal, AUG? Nee, Schweiz, oder?
Österreich, Schweiz?
Oh, ich weiß aber ganz schön viel.
Österreich, okay.
Moment, ich soll wieder so ein Flugzeug reinfliegen.
Ja.
Hat aber nicht gut funktioniert.
Nochmal. Nochmal.
Jetzt aber, jawoll.
Grad hat IQ Flugzeug.
Hi, Happen. 311, danke.
820.
Ah, wie Bruce Lee.
Das sind sie, down die Bruce.
Weiter geht's.
Er ist bei MP5 und wegstellt sich.
Slidern, aschen.
Die hat ein bisschen wenig Schuss, die MP5.
Brauch noch was anderes.
Alter, da gibt's ein bisschen mehr Schuss für.
Da hinten war was.
Au, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. Langsam, langsam.
Kann es sein, dass ich einfach schon ein bisschen zu weit vorne bin?
Alter, die Russen stellsten von allen Seiten.
Wie kommst du denn rein? What? What?
Von wo kam der dann?
Miyamoto hat was gesagt.
Alter, wo ist hier weg?
Wo ist hier weg? Zu viel.
Zu viele Russen am Start.
Wieder nicht mehr.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
What?
Hinter mir?
WTF?
Das ist so die random Call of Duty Spawns jetzt auch im Singleplayer oder wie?
Okay, wir müssen das anders machen.
Ich glaube, wir müssen mit unseren Teammates stellten. Das will das Game von uns.
Das ist Down-Date, das sehe ich ja noch.
Die Waffe, die war im Multiplayer übelst schlecht.
What?
Du musst das Objective machen.
Ja, da will ich doch hin.
Also meine Teammates sind fast schon wie Multiplayer.
Granate?
Die nehmen wir jetzt, die nehmen wir jetzt.
Jawoll, LMG legit, jetzt starten.
Da geht nichts.
Richtig legit.
Ohne Scar.
Dann nehmen wir doch lieber die Scar mit, bevor wir da mit der LMG rumholen.
Flashbangs?
Ammo?
Weg.
Alter, warum?
Ich habe die Waffe gespawnt.
Das war knapp.
Oh Gott, Alter.
Was soll das?
Okay.
Dann swapen wir jetzt die hier so rein, weil ich wollte die Scar haben.
Scar, gib Scar.
Wir machen jetzt einfach einen Molotov dahinten, da können die gar nicht reinlaufen.
Das ist next level.
Das ist schon pre-Molotov.
Random irgendwo dahingeschossen.
Pfeil fährt, aber richtig Pfeil fährt, Leute.
Oh, da wird geschneibert.
Ich hoffe, das ist down, das fahre ich da oben.
Warte ab, wenn die mal explodiert.
Jawoll.
Oh, die Scar macht gut Damage.
Die Scar macht echt gut Damage.
Da sind ja fast one hit mit der Scar.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Zwei hit, two hit.
Two hit mit der Scar.
Scar ist nice, die müssen wir im Multiplayer auch mal ausprobieren.
Die gab es in der Beta ja noch nicht.
Nichts mehr da.
Checkpoint.
Tarmac.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass es am Flughafen keinen einzigen Spot gibt, der sich Tarmac nennt?
Und die das einfach nur immer gerne in News-Sendungen oder in Spielen verwenden.
Es gibt offiziell am Flughafen nichts, was Tarmac heißt.
Big brain jetzt.
Nehm die Aug.
Ich nehm ne Aug, wenn ich ne Aug finde.
Wenn ich ne Aug finde, nehm ich die Aug.
In der Ammo-Kammer.
Okay.
Wenn du Twitch Primes hast, dann hol ich die Aug.
Easy sellout, easy life.
Okay, Aug.
Heli stellt.
Destroy Helikopter.
Gut, wir kennen Call of Duty, wir wissen schon.
Ich muss den Heli jetzt zerstören mit A.
Jawoll.
Ganz schön sneaky, drei Monate, danke schön.
Au.
Warum machst du die Tür auf hier?
Ich die Tür aufmachen, wenn ich da gerade drinnen stehe.
Die gehen wir nicht lang, die gehen hier lang.
Die stellten uns außen vorbei.
Und quickscopten die Russen weg.
Okay, reinrennen ist in dem Spiel wirklich keine allzu gute Idee.
Das Feuer sieht cool aus.
Das hab ich mir noch nicht so genau angeguckt, ehrlich gesagt.
Oh, das ist meiner.
Die sind von der Seite beschlossen.
Komm, der Russen, die spawnen einfach mitten drin.
Ich glaube, das Game möchte mir sagen, ich soll mehr diese
Stellmechanik hier benutzen.
Gut, schon funktioniert das.
Wenn man die Stellmechanik nimmt, dann ist es kein Problem.
Hat der da drin übernachtet, was ist mit dem los?
Ich finde es toll, dass die Gegner mitten drin spawnen.
So, als wollten sie das gar nicht verstecken, dass die
drin spawnen.
Gegner flaschen auch, das ist aber richtig wahnsinnig jetzt.
Oh, der lebt noch.
Ich hab gerade Tara abgeknallt.
Checkpoint, alles gut.
Elite-Soldaten, aber kann ich im Laufen nachladen.
Was sagst du, denke die Stadt ist eine Anlehnung an Kyrgyzstan?
Kein Schimmer.
Ich kenn mich da geografisch in Osteuropa nicht so gut aus.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wo ist der RPG?
Das ist nicht Osteuropa.
Alter, ist ja gut, spawnen nicht hinter mir.
Asien, ja Asien grenzt an Osteuropa.
Weg, weg, nicht wieder aufstehen, bleibst du liegen.
Der bleibt liegen.
Oder auch nicht.
Hat er nach Slomo Doorbreach geschrien?
Achtung, Achtung.
Next Big Brain, Big Brain.
Das habt ihr natürlich alle überlebt da drin, ganz klar.
Oh, ne SCAR.
SCAR oder PKM, also ich behalte mal die PKM.
Was haben wir da sonst noch?
Grenade Launcher, ja so ne Grenade Launcher ist das glaub ich auch nicht verkehrt.
Aber dann mach ich lieber die PKM weg und nehm den Grenade Launcher.
Eklig aus.
Ich bin schon auf dem Weg.
Da kommt was.
Da kommt was angestellt.
Checkpoint, das heißt wenn in Call of Duty Checkpoints kommen dann passiert immer irgendwas.
Grenade, Bashing.
Jetzt, oh Kredatwerfer, Kredatwerfer.
Oh wir Bashing.
Wir Bashing jetzt den LRV.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay wir Bashing doch nicht den LRV.
In den Molotov kommt.
Air Support, jawoll. Air Support. Gif Air Support.
Chopper Gunner.
Ihr müsst mir die Controls nicht erklären, ich hatte den im Multiplayer schon.
Erstmal alles mit Raketen in die Luft sprengen.
Easy Apache, Easy Life.
Oh, alles Down.
Nee, da rennt noch was.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, fuck.
Mir hat was angeschossen.
Oh, das war aber kurzer Chopper Gunner Spaß jetzt.
Also, hier Barkov ist anscheinend der Böse.
Ich blicke ehrlich gesagt nicht durch, wer gerade gegen wen und wer sich basht.
Was, Commander Krieger?
Nee, Commander Karim.
Was hatten sie in MWF?
In Kod 4 doch auch.
Also Haus stürmen.
Es gab so auch diese Safe House Mission in Kod 4.
Wo du diese vier Häuser stürmen musstest.
Ich habe kurz ein paar Obi eingekauft vorher und jetzt geht es auf die Mission.
Wen haben wir denn hier?
Baradiro, ich kann ja aussprechen.
Talani, Price, Binder und Park.
Wie heiße ich nochmal?
Ich weiß nicht, wie der Helden heißt.
Ich meine hier, die, wie nennt man das so?
Die Szenen, das sieht schon ganz cool gemacht aus.
Also für Call of Duty Verhältnisse, ja.
Sieht das echt ganz okay aus.
Aber das ist halt auch wie gesagt Maximum an Grafik.
Mal ins Haus gucken, was da los ist.
Was ist los?
Kann man da reinschoppen ins Haus?
Nee.
Warum muss ich die Leiter hochklettern, wenn die einfach durch die Tür gehen können und die Treppe hochlaufen?
Oder warum können die nicht auch mit der Leiter klettern?
Hä?
Tactical.
Tactical Leiter.
Beste.
Da kann man nichts machen.
Oh.
Was ich gerade nicht mitgekriegt habe, ich habe instant instant getriggert die Waffe.
Also wenn, also wenn das jetzt nicht deaktiviert gewesen wäre, hätte ich die jetzt gleich
abgeknallt aus Versehen.
Wollt ihr denn nicht den Mund zu kleben oder sowas, dass ich nicht rumschreite?
Achtung.
Oh.
Nee, nee hier.
Nee, nee.
Moment.
360.
Was?
Man muss die Thermo West schon mit Style erledigen.
Ja.
Song?
Was soll das?
Was schubst du mich hier einfach weg von der Treppe?
Ich heiße Kyle.
Stimmt.
Ich heiße Kyle, ja.
Auf welcher Schwierigkeit nochmal?
Umgeschrei im Hintergrund?
Stellinskriktion.
Moment.
80 Geräte.
M.
Waschbecken zerstören.
Also sie haben sich Mühe gegeben, ich meine, dass man die Waschbecken zerstören kann,
das hätt's in Call of Duty vorher nicht gegeben.
Die Badewanne nicht, das Klo auch nicht, die Klopapier auch nicht.
Das ist natürlich interessant, dass man das Waschbecken zerschießen kann, aber das Klopapier
absolut intakt bleibt.
Aber so haben sie doch schon verhältnismäßig viel Mühe gegeben.
Benutze mal die Toilette, ich glaub nicht, dass das geht.
Geht nicht.
Kann die.
Kann die Toilette mehlen.
Wisst ihr was, kann man hier Rainbow Six-Style machen?
Oh, huge.
Oh.
Ich glaub, ich hab.
Ich glaub, ich hab die Geisel gerade gekillt.
Das kann ich so nicht auf mich sitzen lassen.
Wir.
Loads Skarvasen jetzt.
Oh.
Ha.
Saved.
Fuck.
Alter, was ist mit den, was ist mit den, mit den Grills in dem Haus?
Was ist mit den Grills in dem Haus los?
Warum wollen die alle mich erschießen?
Ich mein vor allem, ist die, ist die bescheuert?
Die wird erst als Geisel von dem genommen, vorsicht gehalten, ich rette sie und dann
will sie mich erschießen?
WTF?
Ich wollte eigentlich gerade eine Granate reinschmeißen, nachdem ich die Tür, nachdem
ich ein Loch in die Tür gemacht hab.
Sieht aus wie meine Heizung.
Original aus wie meine Heizung.
Warum halten die die Waffen eigentlich so cringe-chab im Stels-Modus?
Nimm mal die Fall.
War da eine Fall?
Oh, huge Fall, nein.
Ich mein, wer braucht so eine komische Pistole, ne?
Aber wir sind hier in der übelsten Stels-Mission, ich kann dich einfach mit der Fall rumwäschen,
das geht nicht.
Wir müssen erst mal stelzen.
Oh, das ist das Treppenhaus.
Erst mal krass durch die Tür gestelzt und dann komm am Treppenhaus raus.
Weg mit dem Nachtsichtgerät, jawoll.
Ich seh' noch mal nix mehr.
Ich weiß, dass das an dem Nachtsichtgerät hin liegt, aber die halten das so.
Ich bin schäpp.
Oben ist eine Frau mit Baby hier, no-spoiler-Blitz.
Was jetzt weiß ich ja schon, dass ich aufpassen muss.
Was ist da hinten?
Nix, da ist Price in der Tür, da kommste nicht vorbei.
Woah, woah, woah.
Die haben sogar gemacht, dass der den wegzieht.
Achtung Leute, jetzt.
Ha, weggeflasht.
Ja doch, easy Zugriff.
Es ist cool gemacht.
Ich find das ist echt cool gemacht bis jetzt.
Gefällt mir bis jetzt wirklich.
Ich mein, ihr wisst, dass ich Games nie so richtig ultra ernst nehme, ja.
Also selbst die Games, die ich echt spannend finde und bis jetzt ist das wirklich cool gemacht.
Ich nehm das nie so ernst, dass ich da so voll mit Fieber bin, wisst ihr ja.
Oh man hört schon das Kind schreien.
Jetzt muss man aufpassen.
Alles gut.
Mal gucken, ob sie sich hier auch Mühe gegeben haben.
Ja, also Physikobjekt auch.
Guck mal, sogar der Teddybär hier kaputt.
Also sie haben sich doch schon ganz gut Mühe gegeben bei dem Game.
Ok, wo ist der Terrorist?
Der stellt es bestimmt hier.
Ja, jetzt machen wir.
Jetzt machen wir, wenn du den Rainbow Six stellst.
Ah, da war er.
Man kann ja sogar in die Leiche reinschießen, geht sonst nicht.
Ach, hier geht es weiter.
Ein bisschen schneller dürfst du schon laufen, Elite Soldat.
Ist erlaubt.
Erstmal ne Flash reinzimmern.
Price hat gesagt.
Alter, Price hat gesagt, ich soll sie droppen.
Und wenn Pause Button Price das sagt.
Guckt Leute hier, die hätten uns in die Luft gesprengt.
Die Frauen haben was gegen uns, ja.
Das ist nur, weil das Game vorher von uns verlangt hat, dass wir Fahrer auf den Hinterkopf gucken.
Weißt du, alles richtig gemacht.
Alles richtig gemacht.
Leute, habt ihr es gesehen?
Habt ihr die IP gesehen?
257 IP.
Wobei, das ist bestimmt Absicht gewesen für Leute, die es kapieren, oder?
Alles klar.
Erklärung, mach ich gleich.
Ich erkläre es gleich.
Das ruckelt, das ist normal, das ist ein Bug, das zwischen Sequenzen ruckelt, da kann ich nichts machen.
Ja, aber ihr, aber ihr natürlich.
Die Katzen sehen gut aus, Paris.
Also müssen wir jetzt den Wolf panischen, nicht dass Peter kommt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, ich meine, die haben jetzt ja Fahrer hier eingeführt, so als Rebellen Anführerin und sowas und ihren Bruder und so.
Weil man spielt dann hier selbst Alex. Ich könnte wetten, dass man später in der Kampagne irgendwie quasi sich entscheiden muss, ob man Fahrer killt oder nicht.
Das würde, das würde so voll in die Call of Duty Logik passen, passlich.
Ist das, ist das der reale Cricks? Den gab es doch in Code 4 auch schon.
Der hat schon Cricks, den gab es doch in Code 4 auch.
Guckt mal, könnt ihr euch daran erinnern?
Cricks, Code 4.
Ah, da ist er. Da ist er. Ja, dann haben sie sich halt ein bisschen inspirieren lassen.
Boah, übel sneezen.
Also mal zur Erklärung, zur Erklärung mit der IP.
Das ist eigentlich relativ einfach. Das Höchste, was möglich ist, das sind 32 Bit. Die höchste Zahl, die irgendwie möglich ist, wenn du das immer in vier mal acht Bytes aufteilst, dann ist ja quasi das Höchste, wenn du ein Byte hast, die höchste Zahl ist 255.
Und zwar, wenn du alles einser hast. Das heißt, 257 als IP geht gar nicht.
Das geht von 0 bis 255. 257 als IP geht nicht.
Aber das ist bestimmt, das haben die bestimmt absichtlich reingeschrieben, dass das, dass die Kenner quasi, ne?
Die Kenner das erkennen.
Richtig Big Brain Roost.
Da ist Cricks am Start. Das finde ich cool.
Leider End.
Was für eine Taste soll das da oben sein? Shift?
Oder was soll mir das sagen? Soll das Shift heißen?
Geht tatsächlich, das bedeutet das Shift. Aber ganz ehrlich, keiner, der irgendwie ein normales Auge hat, kann das lesen, dass es Shift heißen soll, was da oben steht. Wenn die lesen, dass es Shift heißt, sehe ich nicht.
Ok, Moment Leute, mal was testen, mal was testen. Mal was testen und zwar.
Oh, na gut. Na gut, ich wollte nur testen, ob das funktioniert.
Aber es funktioniert. Und was interessant ist, anscheinend stuft das das Game nicht als Friendly Fire ein. Ich nehme mal seine Waffe mit. Aber ich habe selbst eine M4, dann will ich seine Waffe nicht.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, ich bin vor dir Auto. Auto, ich bin vor dir.
Sorry Leute, ich muss das nochmal ausbringen. Ich will nämlich wirklich checken. Oh, das war doch gerade der Quick Save an der Stelle. Ich will checken, wie viel Mühe es sich mit dem Game gegeben hat. Ich will sehen, ob die Autos anhalten, wenn ich vor ihnen bin.
Wahnsinnig. Jedes Mal, wenn wir neu laden, sehen wir jetzt, wie es den Typ zerreißt. Das ist schon ein geiler Speicherpunkt.
Ja, der hat sein Geld verdient, der Typ. Sie verlassen das Schlachtfeld? Jawoll, war klar, war klar.
Wisst ihr, ich stehe am Arsch der Welt, aber kriege erst mal so eine Slow-Mo. Oh, ist das hoch. Oh fuck, ist das hoch.
Da kann man als Elite-Soldat schon mal struggleen, dass man da nicht rüberkommt. Oh, leeres Level. Da haben sie sich definitiv keine Mühe gegeben.
Das ist komplett leeres Level hier dahinter. Komplett Basic Level-Editor mit Sand-Textur.
Was ist da oben los? Wie kommt der Dude dahin? Der war doch eben noch nicht da.
Die haben gesmokt.
Haben wir hier? Nee, das sind unsere. Das sind unsere. Ups, der ist aber auch sehr dämlich gerade vor mich gerannt.
Wo kommt meine M14 hin?
Alter, was ist hier los? Ich habe das Gefühl, die schießen um die Ecke.
Wo kommt der her? Ist der gerade vom Dach gesprungen?
Die M14 ist nice, die haut übelst rein.
Noch Smoke, erstmal Smoke, damit man durch kann. Was haben wir denn hier? Eine AK. Eine AK kann man immer mitnehmen, da macht man nichts falsch.
Das ist ja so die Feld-Waldwiesen-Terroristen-Waffe quasi in dem Game.
Oh, hier sind wieder Grenades. Lange schon mit dem Sub-Zock-Baste-Bastero?
Warum kann ich die Granate nicht zerschießen? Die diffusen wir diesmal. Nee, nee, ich teste diesmal nicht.
Oder soll ich wieder testen, Leute? Was meine ich, soll ich testen oder soll ich diffusen?
Ich glaube das Game, checkt es echt nicht, dass das Friendly Fire ist. Das ist glaube ich verbackt.
Wupp, Lull.
Ok, das geht nicht kaputt.
Was ist da? Was hat man da? Dragunov.
Schneiber wäre schon nicht verkehrt, oder? Schneiber? Kommen wir nehmen die Schneiber mit.
Ich glaube das ist so eine typische Call of Duty-Geschichte, wo man über einen gewissen Punkt laufen muss, dass es weiter geht.
Tank. Ja, Digga. Kann man draufklettern?
Nee, kann man nicht. Jetzt nur noch Trickshots. Da ist meine Sense nicht hoch genug.
Ich muss in Deckung.
Smoke. Eine Runde Smoke. Jetzt hier, ach, da kann er auch, da kann er nirgendwo drüber hüpfen.
Alles tot? Jawoll, rein da.
Ouch, ouch, ouch. Die hauen echt gut rein. Ich glaube ich muss wirklich mehr diese Cover Mechanics verwenden.
Alter. Die machen aber echt Damage, wenn du da rein slidest.
Okay, wir wissen jetzt ja, dass da links einer stellt. Warum machen die so viel Damage? Ich hab schon auf Normal gestellt, oder? Die waren hinten einer fast.
Ach, guck mal, bei dem aus dem Rucksack kann man sich eine Grenade nehmen. Cool.
Ups. Was soll man das denn jetzt erkennen so auf die Schnelle? Ach, jetzt aber. Ist nix.
Krankenhaus Level. Hat mir auch noch nie ein Krankenhaus Level. Hat aber nochmal Glück gehabt hier. Grenade.
Die brauchen ja drei Stunden. So treffen die einen irgendwie gar nicht, ne? Das ist ja fast hier schon Cover Shooter Style.
Wo ist der nächste?
Keiner da. Keiner da.
Der muss erstmal in die KI geladen werden.
Da würde ich auch immer stehen, wenn ich Terrorist bin. Genau in dieser Ecke.
Mach mal den Test, ob wenn du lange um die Ecke schaust, ob sie dich überhaupt treffen. Das ist eine gute Idee. Das könnt ihr erstmal ausprobieren.
Da musst du schneller sein. Da musst du schneller sein.
Ok, testen wir das mal. Wenn ich um die Ecke gucke, ob ich dann getroffen werde. Gucken wir mal um die Ecke. Ich glaube, ich werde auch so nicht getroffen.
Wo ist hier was?
Erstmal hier durch. Da ist einer. Ok, jetzt. Ich bleib mal hier stehen. Mal gucken, ob ich getroffen werde.
Die sehen mich überhaupt nicht. Guck mal, die sehen mich überhaupt nicht. Ok, ich werde doch getroffen.
Head-ditch. Head-ditch-Taktik.
What? Was war das? Ich bin nicht über England Halle gelaufen, ne?
Fuck.
Wo ist die Falle hier? Ach da.
Ok, jetzt müssten wir sie entschärfen. Nein, nicht testen. Jetzt müssten wir sie wirklich mal entschärfen.
Sind sie alle down, alle gestreckt. Noch 5 Ammo und Schneiper haben wir. Dann nehmen wir mal hier eine AK mit. GIF. Jawoll.
Vivi, naja, eigentlich nicht, weil ich check auch nicht, was passiert.
Wie findest du, dass es kein Free-For-All gibt? Kacke, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das so ist. Ok Leute, Moment, testen.
Fuck, ich hab meinen. Ah, da ist er wieder. Ok. Ich hab meinen Granatwerfer weggeworfen.
Ok, Sgt. Griggs macht es nix aus. Ja, Griggs hat Story-Immunity.
Das ist Hauptcharakter, geh ich mal von aus. Den kann man nicht killen. Da ist er. Der Wolf. Der Oma Sülemann.
Preach. Endlich. Doorpreach. Was ich halt... Slim Economy, genau das gleiche wollte ich auch sagen.
Wir haben hier eine halbe Stunde uns durch Krankenhaus geballert und die sitzen einfach mal da drinnen und nehmen einen Film auf.
Einfach so, ich hab nicht mitgekriegt, dass um uns gerade alle Leute erschossen werden. Wir machen jetzt erstmal ein Video.
So wie man das von Influencern halt kennt. Alter, das Game, she baitet mich aber hart.
Was? Da fuck, ja was denn nur? Wenn ich zurück gehe, ist die Mission vorbei und wenn ich an die Tür ran gehe...
Ah, jetzt hier. Die Fuse. Können wir jetzt aber beeilen. Da fuck. Game, please. Sagt mir was ich machen soll. Alter.
Okay, jetzt haben wir es richtig gemacht. Jetzt haben wir den Wolf gecaptchert.
Sülemann. Bei dem Namen fällt mir ein, hat jemand hier Jack Ryan Staffel 1 geguckt.
Gab es doch auch irgendeinen Sülemann. Ja, die Augen sehen ein bisschen kaputt aus.
Wahrscheinlich ist er blind. Ja, das denke ich mal, dass sie einem was sagen wollen.
Jetzt aber ziemlich viel Anele angesagt.
Das wird sie Botschaft verteidigen. Das ist übrigens nicht bei euch asynchron, das wagt rum die Katzen.
Und merkt euch, wenn ihr immer möglichst kryptisch redet.
Das Game hat 129 Gigabyte. Warum auch immer.
Kyle ist wieder da. Hieß FPS Russia, nicht auch Kyle im echten Leben. Ja, 130 Gigabyte.
Price ist wieder am Start.
Oh nein, nicht immer das gleiche, please Call of Duty. Kann in Call of Duty nicht ein Heli normal landen, in dem man drin sitzt.
Okay.
Das ist ihm ins Gesicht geflogen. Nee, du hast dich verkockt. Kann nicht sein.
Ich glaube, wir müssen echt die Botschaft verteidigen.
Schau mal, schlusssicher. Ich meine, er ist der ultra Elite Soldat, aber der schleicht die Treppe langsam in meine Oma runter.
Wo ist das Mann? Der kommt auch vorwärts.
Die haben auch so ganz wenig klischeebehaftete Namen.
Da ist er. Soll ich den aufmachen?
Kann nicht auf.
Soll ich jetzt aufmachen oder nicht? Jetzt ist eh zu spät.
Oh, macht er einfach die Tür vor mir zu.
Kannst du mir Waffe geben, please?
Da sind sie.
Erstmal reingeflankt.
Ich hab nur eine Pistole. Brauche ich was Gescheites?
Die Pistole macht gefühlt mehr Damage als die LMGs und Sword Rifles.
Bricht hier nicht irgendeine Waffe? Ah, da.
Shotgun. Shotgun nehmen wir doch hier indoor ganz gerne.
Shotgun ist Pock.
Ja, Shotgun ist nice hier drin.
Granate. Price juckt das nicht. Price ist die Granate. Egal.
Hat Plot Armor aus dem Vorstand.
Oh, die Shotgun hier drin ist schon cool.
Die hat jetzt gedacht, ich seh dich nicht oder was?
Stellst du dich hier vorbei so?
Gleich komm ich von hinten, gleich komm ich von hinten, da passiert aber nix.
Ist das ne Auto-Shotgun hier?
Ist das ne Auto-Shotgun oder ist das die gleiche?
Der ist die gleiche.
Nein, nein, Price. Ich mach schon auf.
Price gesaved.
Okay, wir müssen brauchen wir noch ne ordentliche, was ist denn das?
Auch ne Shotgun. Das wären wir jetzt aber ein bisschen viele Shotguns.
Dann brauchen wir irgendwas Automatisches.
SMG ist hier, indoor ist beste.
Moin, peinlicher Affe.
Sarah, wie kommt ihr denn dahin?
Ich wette mit dir, wenn ich dich jetzt kille, ist die Story dann uns neu laden, das geht nicht.
Okay, Überwachungs-Ding.
Das Statue sieht ganz schön dreckig aus.
Ja, super clevere Idee, erstmal wenn der Typ kommt da hin zu laufen.
ApplepieTV, Dankeschön Twitch Prime.
Wo muss ich die Olle jetzt rumkommandieren?
Ich muss Frauen in dem Game rumkommandieren.
Das dürfen aber nicht die falschen Leute sehen.
Leute, ich bin weiß, männlich, heterosexuell und 35.
Ich kann nicht in dem Game einfach Frauen rumkommandieren.
Das ist heute nicht mehr drinnen.
Jetzt ist die große Preisfrage, ist das eine Mission, wo ich verlieren kann oder ist das eine Mission, die einfach so funktioniert?
Wahrscheinlich doch, ich muss aufpassen, dass die mich nicht sehen.
Du kannst verlieren, okay.
Das heißt, ich gucke mal, bis die weggucken.
Jetzt gucken sie weg.
Das ist eigentlich mal ganz coole Abwechslung.
Oh, da kommt einer.
Das hat er natürlich nicht gesehen, ist klar.
Das hat sich echt ganz cool gemacht.
Ich meine, ob man das jetzt in einem Cod braucht, die Mission, weiß ich nicht.
Genau, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil, den Cod willst du reinrennen und bashen.
Lass ihn liegen, lass ihn liegen.
Big Brain Soldaten hier.
Geh mal dahinter.
Oder da?
Geh mal dahin, Stacey.
Oh, nein, nein.
Die Office grills wieder.
Moment, wo bin ich?
Moment, ich blicke gerade nicht mehr durch.
Wo ist sie denn überhaupt?
Ach, da.
Okay, Stacey, einfach schneller sein, bis der Dude sich umdreht.
Nicht durch die Mitte.
Alter.
Okay, jetzt, go, go, go.
Nein, Stacey, du läufst immer falsch rum.
Jetzt.
Schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell.
Hopp, genau, jetzt läuft es in die richtige Richtung.
Das kriegt er nicht mit.
Ah ja, die Gegner sind schon ein bisschen brain dead, oder?
Okay, jetzt dürfen wir weiter bashen.
Was ist denn unsere?
Vielleicht hört er schlecht.
Jetzt wird es sein.
Was? Ach so.
Ich muss gleich mal kurz was zu Essen holen.
Oh ja, das ist, glaube ich, eine bessere Waffe über Range.
Der lebt noch?
Sorry, Captain Price.
Du sahst so terroristenmäßig aus auf einmal.
Au.
Was gab es denn noch?
Gar nichts.
Ach so, was ich mir holen werde.
Ich hol mir von der Mittag, ich hab mir am Mittag Pizza bestellt.
Und zwar, halt euch fest.
Sauce Hollandaise Pizza mit Brokkoli und Hähnchen.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, was die meisten Leute jetzt denken.
Die meisten Leute denken jetzt halt irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Aber ich sag euch, das ist echt Pock.
Das ist nicht Dominos.
Nee, das ist nicht von Dominos.
Dominos ist die schlechteste Pizza Kette ever.
Was willst du, Nedis?
Verstehe nicht.
Doch, hat er gesagt, Dominos sackt.
Übels.
Ich würde nur enttäuscht, wenn ich bei Dominos bestellt hab.
Die haben ja Joey's Pizza in Deutschland gekauft.
Das war noch ein bisschen besser.
Ich bestell nie wieder was bei Dominos.
Rein da.
Führt zu.
M14.
Ja, wir nehmen eine M14, M14 und eine Falle.
Das überrange ganz gut.
Sag mal, ich mein, Farah ist doch eigentlich so die Anführerin,
so das Miliz-Anführer-Grill, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab.
Warum darf die auf irgendwelche Militärstützpunkte mit?
Und stellt's damit Price rum?
Haben die keine Bedenken, dass die vielleicht doch nicht so
freundlich gesonnen ist, der ganzen Sache?
Ich weiß nicht, ich würd mir da Gedanken machen.
Ich glaub, das ist zu viel Gedanken, die ich mir da bei der Cut Story mache.
Jetzt wird geschneibert.
Jetzt geht's nur noch 360-Header.
Wenn sogar Price sagt, ich soll scopen, dann ist das eher...
Warum keine Military-Age-Girls?
Wie ist das mit Gleichberechtigung?
Das geht aber nicht.
Darf ich da jetzt draufballern?
Die meisten Lieferservices da ist, geb ich dir recht.
Die meisten Lieferservices gefallen mir auch nicht.
Ist doch so.
Gut, wenn die herkommen, dann kann ich die snipen.
Wo bestellst du immer?
Ich bestell bei keinen Ketten mehr.
Bestell bloß noch bei uns.
Bei Asiastelz, Hähnchelstelz, Pizzakram, Dudel.
Wir haben ja alles hier.
Meine dumme Frage, weiß jemand, wie lange die Kampagne geht?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir das heute hinkriegen bis 21 oder 22 Uhr.
Fünf Stunden, das könnten wir packen.
Ich seh nix.
Wo ist was?
Okay, ich soll was machen.
Ich weiß noch nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ich soll ein Mörder schießen.
Die kommen jetzt da nur raus, weil ich die Flair geschossen hab oder was?
Komm, was soll man hier rumstelzen, wir gehen da jetzt hin.
Lasst mich hier rüber.
Ich darf nicht raus.
Ich muss auf dem Dach bleiben, Leute.
Geht nicht, das Game möchte von mir, dass ich auf dem Dach bleibe.
Huge Level Design und jetzt muss ich wieder Flair schießen.
Das Game ist so was von uncut.
Ja, sehr ernsthaft, weil es nix kann.
War doch voll drauf.
Wow, was jetzt?
Wie ist da Gefahren?
Der Typ wird down werden müssen.
Ganz schön viele.
Noch mal ne Flair her.
Warum bewegen die sich?
Ich durfte nicht ne Flair schießen.
Ich dachte, die wollten uns angreifen, nicht wir die.
Oh, da kommt was.
Da kommt was.
Ich bräuchte wieder so ein Remote, so ein RC-Plane von vorhin.
Kann man die nicht einfach killen jetzt?
48 FPS, weil es flüssiger läuft.
Ich bin schon vom Roof runter.
Meinst du den Preis, wie lange ich dafür brauche, wenn einer mit Mörser drauf schießt?
Ich darf immer noch nicht rüber.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht der intended way, wie ich das gerade mache.
Wo muss ich hin?
Defend, okay, einfach nur defend.
Ach guck mal, die Mauer ist kaputt.
Das ist ja nice.
War noch was Damage.
Okay, wir machen Slider, oh fuck, nein, da stehen ja um mich rum herum.
Einmal, die sind gespawnt.
Erstmal ne Granate rein, das kann nicht schaden.
Jetzt ne Runde Flash drüber übers Auto.
Jetzt werden sie gebashed.
Ich habe immer noch das Gefühl, dass ich das nicht intended mache gerade.
Hallo, wo kommst denn du her?
Ich glaube, ich mache das echt nicht intended, was ich hier...
Ich glaube, ich sollte da drinnen sein und irgendwie Defender-Stells machen.
Ah ne.
Regroup, wir sind fertig, easy, wir haben es geschafft.
Das wars.
Siehst du die Flares? Nee, gibt es keine Flares mehr.
Man sieht echt nichts.
Also bei mir sieht es in der Vorschau ganz okay aus.
Ich meine, es ist halb Nacht.
Ich habe 6900 Bitrate.
Wer geht nicht?
Das ist schon mehr als 90% der Leute auf Twitch streamen.
Also ich sehe es gerade bei mir in der Vorschau.
Das sieht doch ganz okay aus.
Das ist halt so.
Wenn das Bild dunkel ist und vor allem wenn es ein paar Lichtquellen hat,
da tun sie alle Encoder schwer.
Zum Glück liegt da eine Leiter rum.
Easy.
Laser, jetzt.
Okay.
Oh nice.
Erstmal schön das Gebäude kaputt machen.
Gucken wir mal, wie viel wir vom Gebäude kaputt machen können.
Wahrscheinlich nicht so viel.
Eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts.
Siehst ihr was? Ich muss noch was ausprobieren.
Okay, das geht nicht.
Also ich gucke es mir jetzt gerade in meiner Vorschau an auf Fullscreen.
Also das sieht einfach so aus, wie halt H264 mit nicht so hoher Bitrate nachts eben aussieht.
Ich meine, ich habe keine 25 MBit oder so.
Kann ich ja nicht machen auf Twitch.
Weg.
Wie?
Eats.
Kannst du mal treffen, Alter?
Jawoll.
Jetzt schreckt du.
Aber es gibt nichts mehr.
Es gibt keine Raketen mehr.
Ach doch, wieder.
Jawoll.
Die werden aber schon hart geschreckt, die Tuts hier.
Ich glaube die Autos sind schon alle in die Luft geflogen.
Da habe ich net Luft.
Was?
Ah, der Laser ist all.
Batterie leer.
Runter hier.
Ne Moment, hier darf ich nicht lang.
Hier darf ich nicht lang, das ist falsch.
Wo möchte ich Call of Duty, dass ich lang gehe?
Dahin, okay, mach ich.
Mach ich.
Erstmal schön butt-sliden zum Gegner, da treffen sie einen nicht.
Die sind eh nicht allzu clever, muss ich sagen.
Jawoll.
Oh, der hat schon eingeschlagen.
Achtung jetzt hier.
Huge Nade.
Mach ich mal off, ich mach off.
Nein, ich mach das.
Wir sind nicht in der Lage die Tür aufzukriegen.
Ja, ist klar.
Natürlich.
Guck dir die Gebäude an.
Die sehen ziemlich viereckig aus.
Da campt er.
Da campt er in der Ecke, fast wie Multiplayer, als wollen sie die Leute schon mal darauf vorbereiten, was sie erwartet.
Wie kommt denn die Granate in den Raum?
Wie kommt die Granate in den Raum, die ist mir im Gang entgegengeflogen gekommen.
What?
Da ist die Granate, wie ist die in den Raum gekommen?
Zemtex, meinste die hat mich gestickt?
Ich glaube nicht, dass die mich gestickt hat, das war irgendeine Call of Duty Logik.
Alle Terroristen Gound.
Jawoll, alle weg.
Was haben wir hier noch zu bieten?
AK.
Oder 15 Terroristen Gun, da kann man nichts falsch machen, da gibt es genug.
Guck mal.
LMG.
Petas LMG, das behalten wir mal kurz.
Wo ging es raus?
Das lädt ja 5 Stunden nach.
Das für 50 Schuss.
Jetzt stellzen wir da mal rein.
Erstmal noch eine Runde Flaschen.
Naja, ich bin da schon wieder drinnen.
Ah nee, hier geht es gar nicht rein.
Alles, was ich gerade fremdlich feiern habe.
Au, au, au, au, au, au, au.
Fort.
Du bist die Schalke.
Nee, der ist schon Down.
Das ist einer von mir.
Man erkennt gar nicht so genau, was Freund und Feind ist irgendwie.
Komische MG, ich brauch was anderes.
Das MG sackt.
Es braucht 5 Stunden zum Nachladen.
Wieder 5 Stunden nachladen.
Guck mal.
Das bin ja ich.
Das fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Das finde ich cool, dass die die gleichen Spieler in die gleiche Mission packen.
So, erstmal wieder was ordentliches nehmen.
Das war knapp.
Wo kommt denn Stacey auf einmal her?
Die ist von der Botschafter hingestellt.
Doorpreach.
Leute, jetzt endlich mal ne Doorpreach.
Nein, gibt kein Doorpreach.
Die können das auch.
Der Wolf ist weg.
Das Vogel wieder.
So wirklich check ich die Story jetzt ja nicht oder ist die Story einfach nicht vorhanden?
So nach dem Motto die Russen oder besser gesagt die Terroristen haben russisches Gas und alle haben jetzt irgendwie Schuss und wollen sie bashen.
Und das sind die Freiheitskämpfer.
Ich glaube das hat einfach nicht mehr Story.
Tell me a Joke.
Treffen sich zwei Jäger beide tot.
Mit dem Los will er den jetzt weg hammern.
Für mich sah das so aus als will er dem den Kopf weg hammern.
Guck mal, der steht mit dem Hammer da und der macht den Kopf so runter als hämmert dem jetzt den Kopf weg.
Auf Schneiber Mission.
Schneiber.
Das ist so einfach.
Ich muss mal hier Licht anmachen.
Ich muss was zu essen holen.
Ich hab übel Hunger.
Ich hol mir jetzt die zwei Stücke Pizza vor der Mittag.
Und ihr könnt euch mal überlegen oder was mich mal interessieren würde.
Ich bin da nur zwei drei Minuten weg.
Was mich interessieren würde, was ihr bis jetzt vor der Kampagne denkt.
Ich für meinen Teil muss sagen, ich hab am Anfang gedacht ich blicke nicht durch.
Bis mir dann aufgefallen ist, es gibt eigentlich überhaupt nichts durchzublicken.
Es gibt Engländer, es gibt Russen und die Terroristen haben von den Russen Gas gestohlen.
Und jetzt guck mal was passiert.
So das ist alles.
Und irgendwie ist es doch ein bisschen langweilig.
Ich hab mir jetzt eigentlich mehr davon versprochen muss ich ehrlich sagen.
So ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Ich geh mal kurz was zu essen holen.
So das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
So ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal was essen kurz.
Was gibt's denn sonst so Neues worüber wir nochmal eine Runde schwätzen können?
Sagt mal Leute was gibt's denn für spannende Sachen worüber man mal was zu sagen muss?
Eine schon am Pennen.
Was?
Man macht das Key Server Update?
Mach den!
Jetzt erstmal langsam.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal.
Ich hab euch jetzt erstmal dieses Scan Zeug gemacht.
Und dann muss ich ja auch noch die fertige Sache.
Muss ich ja nochmal seinem Chef schicken.
Aber es geht ja schon benutzbar.
Und dann wenn ich wieder Zeit hab.
Man sieht die Emotes nicht.
Die Emotes nicht.
Ach man sieht die Emotes nicht.
Stimmt wisst ihr warum man die Emotes nicht sieht?
Weil Display Capture und Game Capture.
Jetzt haben wir Display Capture.
Ich glaube das lag, dass es ein bisschen geleckt hat lag daran.
Dass ich Modern Warfare mit Display Capture aufgenommen hab.
Und nicht mit Game Capture.
Und jetzt hab ich ja auf Game Capture umgestellt.
Und seitdem funktioniert es.
Vor Black Friday.
Ja wieso?
Es funktioniert doch erstmal.
Was muss man denn wichtiges machen?
Aber jetzt sieht man die Emotes wieder.
Jetzt seh ichs auch in der Vorschau.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit Emotes eingeplant und ihr habt die alle nicht gesehen.
Das ist ja kacke.
Das sagt ja.
Den haben wir hier noch als neuen Subs am Start der Apple Pie TV.
Ganz schön Sneaky.
Ach nee hatten wir schon.
Aber trotzdem nochmal.
THX.
Ja also Chat.
Ihr könnt jetzt irgendwas erzählen oder mich irgendwas fragen oder irgendwas wissen wollen.
Weil ich muss jetzt eh noch meine Pizza futtern.
Wenn ihr nix sagt.
Dann werd ich jetzt einfach 5 Minuten vor mich hinkrauen.
Video schauen.
Was denn für ein Video?
Wie viele Haare hast du noch?
Ich hab nicht gezählt.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr so die Masse.
Nee das hältst schon Grenzen.
Wieso benutzt du Chromium?
Das ist relativ schwierig zu beantworten.
Ich weiß es selbst gar nicht so genau.
Wie das ruckelt.
Ich glaube ich hab angefangen Chromium zu benutzen.
Weil irgendwas mit Chromecast gespackt hat.
Es hat insofern was mit Chromecast gespackt.
Ich wollte kein Chromecast verwenden.
Aber irgendwie hat es doch was mit Chromecast gemacht.
Und hat immer drüben auf meinem Shield TV rumgespackt am Fernseher.
Da hab ich dann einfach einen Browser genommen.
Der eben keinen Chromecast drin hat.
Aber mittlerweile ist das gefixt.
Eigentlich könnte ich wieder Chrome nehmen.
Ich meine ich hab hier eh alles drauf.
Firefox drauf.
Chrome drauf.
Chromium drauf.
Opera in der VM drauf.
Vivaldi.
Ansonsten noch Edge.
Internet Explorer.
Alles drauf.
Ja Max Blanco so sieht es aus.
Das gute ist hier an dem Neuskate.
Man hört mich gar nicht schmatzen.
Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Also ich hab hier gerade die letzten zwei Stücke Pizza Hollandaise.
Das ist sehr nice.
Also das Overlay von Cod ist nicht so ganz flüssig würde ich sagen.
Wenn man das hier Overlayed da geht es besser.
Wo warst du die Jahre?
Da wo ich vorher auch war.
Oder was meinste?
Also auf Twitch bin ich schon seit 2017 oder so.
Vor ungefähr zwei Jahren habe ich angefangen auf Twitch zu streamen.
Allerdings natürlich nicht unter meinem YouTube Namen.
Weil das dann ursprünglich gar kein Account zum Streamen war.
Und da bin ich ja schon wieder eine Weile auch auf YouTube am Start.
Kennst du das Windows 10 Deep Loader?
Nee.
Aber ich kann es mir mal angucken.
Verubert mal.
Was macht das?
Aha.
Also das deinstalliert den ganzen Mist das schallendmäßig drauf ist oder was?
Ich sehe installiert ist auch Candy Crush.
Jawoll.
Das ist ja schon mal ganz sinnvoll.
Finde ich keine schlechte Idee.
Und ich mein.
Es hat 3000 Sterne auf GitHub.
Das Ding scheint ja relativ beliebt zu sein.
Ich muss ich muss ein bisschen Cod im Hintergrund aufhalten.
Weil ich mein wir haben immerhin noch das auf der Kategorie Call of Duty stehen.
Wir machen auch gleich weiter.
Aber ich muss erst mal meine Pizza fertig fordern.
Was hältst du von der Einstellung der Wind Updates von Windows 7?
War logische Konsequenz von dem was Microsoft gesagt hat.
Es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund nicht auf Windows 10 zu wechseln.
Oder wie sieht es eurer Meinung nach aus?
Falls noch jemand bei Windows 7 ist.
Warum seid ihr noch auf Windows 7 und wollt nicht auf Windows 10 wechseln?
Also aus meiner Sicht gibt es keinen Grund.
Warum?
Mit was ist die Pizza belegt?
Wie gesagt Brokkoli, Sauce, Hollandaise und Hähnchen.
8 GB Update für Modern Warfare.
Okay.
Ich meine wir sollten das Game nochmal neu starten.
Wobei es läuft doch jetzt eigentlich ganz.
Danke für das schnelle Video zur VPN.
Ja das war ein guter Thema Vorschlag.
Weil du nicht der einzige warst der das haben wollte.
Die Einstellungen sind unabschiedlich.
Es gibt die Systemeinstellungen einmal neu und einmal an wie Windows 7.
Das stimmt.
Da hast du recht.
Aber ich finde es ist nicht wirklich ein Grund nicht zu wechseln.
Ja Windows 10 hat auch viel was mich nervt.
Aber das macht die anderen die alten Windows jetzt nicht besser für mich.
Windows 10 ist halt das neueste und das neueste ist halt auch immer das am besten supportetste.
Allein schon deswegen macht es für mich Sinn.
Ja ich gebe dir recht.
Dass es total unübersichtlich ist.
Das habe ich mich ja auch schon öfters im Stream darüber aufgeregt.
Wie unübersichtlich das Ganze ist.
Aber für mich wäre es zumindest kein Grund.
Gasti YouTube sagt meine Schule ist noch auf Windows 7.
Dann ist deine Schule aber schon voll fortschrittlich.
Nächstes Video AMD vs Intel.
Habe ich das nicht schon mal gemacht?
Ich sehe da.
Der Aua hat das schon gemacht.
Das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Allerdings wenn es um AMD vs Intel geht.
Wenn ich mir aktuell einen Desktop Rechner zusammenbauen würde.
Dann würde ich es mit einer Ryzen CPU machen.
Weil die ganz neuen CPUs die Intel vorgestellt hat sind auch wieder recht konkurrenzfähig.
Aber da sieht man mal die unglaublich viel Kohle Intel geschaffelt hat.
Wenn die einfach mal so die Preise für ihre CPUs halbieren können und es ihnen nicht juckt.
Corazon97E Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Big Brain.
Hi IQ Sub.
So ein Stück Pizza noch.
Dann geht es weiter.
Also Official Dark Toasty ich würde dir empfehlen wenn du nur unter Windows spielen willst.
Und auch unter Linux arbeiten willst mach den Linux VM.
Linux VM habe ich ja auch hier am Start.
Benutze ich ja auch immer regelmäßig im Stream.
Natürlich ein bisschen langsamer.
Oder ein bisschen paar Sachen nicht möglich die native möglich sind.
Beispiel Grafikkarte durchreichen oder sowas.
Aber das will man meistens auch eh nicht machen.
Dafür hast du den super Support was Hardware angeht und was Spiele angeht und was Software angeht von Windows.
Und für alles andere kannst du Linux nach VM verwenden.
Ich nehme das immer auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Woher kennt dein Chef eigentlich deinen YouTube Channel?
Da muss ich euch was erzählen Leute.
Huge.
Sorry Ink.
Also.
Um jetzt erstmal die Frage direkt zu beantworten.
Der kennt meinen Channel.
Weil der mich auch schon eine Weile kennt.
Und er mich schon kannte bevor ich mit YouTube angefangen habe.
Der war ja auch früher.
Wie ich in dem einen Video erzählt habe.
Der war ja auch mal Azubi bei diesem Internet Provider.
Zwei Jahre vor mir.
Wo wir gearbeitet haben.
Der war am gleichen Laden früher.
Also den kenne ich schon ziemlich lang.
Und der hat auch viel Battlefield 3 gespielt.
Und dann hat sich damals meine Battlefield 3 Videos angeguckt.
Ich habe sogar noch irgendwo ein Heli Gameplay von dem.
Und ich meine wer kann schon bitte schon sagen dass er von seinem Chef eine Battlefield 3 Heli Gameplay hat.
Da gibt es nicht so viele.
Necuroc.
Twitch Prime.
Drei Monate.
Oh Big Brain.
IQ vom Chat steigt ins Unermessliche.
So und jetzt wollte ich euch was erzählen.
Und zwar.
Ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
Ich habe letztens.
Das glaubt mir wieder keiner.
Ich habe letztens ein Video gemacht.
Dazu.
Das mache ich auf der Arbeit.
So.
Und ich habe ja in dem Video am Anfang.
Noch gesagt.
Ich muss jetzt mal bei der Realität bleiben.
Weil.
Ich weiß dass man Chef manchmal zuguckt.
Also ich habe gesagt ich darf es jetzt nicht so.
Übertreiben oder untertreiben.
Und da habe ich auch ein bisschen.
Über über Arbeit was man so macht.
Gehalt und sonst was.
Und am Freitag.
Was ich schon als ich gehen wollte.
Ich habe ich habe eigentlich gesagt.
Ich habe keine Zeit.
Ich muss jetzt weg.
Da hat er gemeint.
Komm noch mal kurz mit.
Und da hat er mir den Brief in die Hand gedrückt.
Wo drinnen stand.
Ja ne Moment.
Er hat erst mal angefangen.
Zu sagen.
Er hat erst mal gesagt.
Ich habe ein Video geguckt.
Und.
So nach dem.
Ja was.
Ja.
Er ist auch super zufrieden.
Und.
In dem Video hatte er noch mal.
Quasi dann auch gehört.
Was ich alles machen würde.
Und dann hat er mir den Brief umgeschlagen.
In die Hand gedrückt.
Dass ich jetzt.
Quasi.
In eine.
Gehaltsgruppe.
Tarif.
Höher eingestuft werde.
Seit diesem Monat.
Das hat mich echt.
Hat mich auch überrascht.
Ja.
Ich habe ja.
Ich habe sogar noch ein Video gesagt.
Ich muss mal.
Ich muss mein Chef mal wieder nerven.
Wegen mehr Kohle.
Jetzt bin ich.
Gehaltsgruppe.
Sechs.
Ich glaube.
Neun gibt es.
Das ist nice.
Gibt es jetzt.
Glaub.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Wie viel mehr Geld es gibt.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Es gibt.
Wir haben ja letztens.
Im Stream geguckt.
Vgs.
Tarif.
Vertragen.
Versicherung.
Vorher war ich fünf.
Mit Bonus.
Und jetzt bin ich.
Sechs.
Ich bin hier unten.
Weil ich schon 14 Jahre dabei bin.
Und das mal 14.
14.
Monats.
Gehaltsgruppe.
Und das mal.
14.
35 stunden, ne 30 stunden normalerweise normalerweise müsste ich
37,85 oder so arbeiten und ich arbeite nur vier tage in die woche also quasi 30 stunden
Ich finde das ist auch ein ganz gutes
Pensum ja ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das ausgehalten habe früher
Tatsächlich da fünf tage die woche zu arbeiten und nebenbei youtube zeugs zu machen
Mein vertrag mein vertrag war für war für 37,85 stunden aber den haben wir umgestellt auf
irgendwie 30,5 oder so
Das habe ich hier rahe raven
Das habe ich letzten sonntag schon erzählt weil die leute immer gefragt haben
Und vier tage ist top ich habe mir sogar letzten schon überlegt ob ich nicht einfach weil ich
kriege in letzter zeit so viele sell-out angebote auf per mail auch ja
So viele sell-out angebote die echt attraktiv sind so was wie Ghost Recon zum beispiel
Und ich habe mir so gedacht habe sie auch schon auf twitter gepostet ich habe mir so gedacht ich
meine ich habe ich habe immer relativ wenig sell-out gemacht ja ich habe eigentlich außer
für sachen sowie el gato und so was ich als selbst benutzt habe ich eigentlich nie sell-out gemacht
und letztens so morgen ist morgens als ich aufgestanden bin und im bad gesessen habe
habe dann meistens noch so zehn minuten zeit da bleibe ich im bad sitzen mache die
heizung am lüfter an und gucke ein bisschen auf dem handy rum und da ist mir eingefallen
warum machst du nicht einfach mehr sell-out weil war ganz ehrlich als würde manuel neuer cola
geil finden dankeschön nico cs stufe 1 abonniert zwei monate plus 50 wisst ihr was ich meine oder
als würde das gibt es ja noch für sportler die die werbung machen oder bleiben wir mal
manuel neuer als findet der cola so geil er findet cola im werbesport geil weil er kohle
für kriegt habe ich mir gedacht warum mache ich das nicht einfach die angebote sind gut
ja gibt es was für go streets gab es gibt was für irgendwie so ein komisches komisches mobile
mmo es gibt was für für gut was es immer gibt es in diese ganze wargaming geschichten und dann
hänge ich mir als genau typico also also habe ich okay warum warum eigentlich nicht und zwar
werde ich das so machen bisher habe ich meine sell-out sehr immer versucht so ein bisschen in
bisschen so in meinen style von den von den videos einzubinden ja also ich habe bei dem
video gesagt so ich denke das vielleicht was für leute die koop spielen wollen und ein bisschen
so wie ich normalerweise auch ein video machen würde ohne sell-out so und ich habe mir überlegt
ich werde das bei den bei den bei den sell-out videos einfach so machen ich werde sagen am
anfang hey das ist werbung oder aber im video sagen hey es ist werbung und dann halt kurz mal
eine minute oder 30 sekunden erzählen warum warum man sich irgendwas angucken soll was die
marketing sachen sagen ich werde nicht sagen dass das meiner meinung nach toll ist oder dass ich
davon überzeugt bin oder so ich werde einfach sagen jungs werbung und ein paar schöne marketing
sprüche machen was ihnen halt so gefällt ich meine guckt euch das beispielsweise an
linus tech tips macht das elektro boom macht das das machen sau viele channels und da ist
eigentlich finde ich heutzutage überhaupt nichts dagegen einzuwenden solange man das halt nicht so
verkauft als wäre es deine eigene überzeugung das finde ich ist das verwerfliche falls wenn das
leute machen das waren beauty channels zum beispiel ganz gerne so mein gott ich habe heute zufällig
dieses tolle parfüm gefunden oder bin ich ja so glücklich dass ich das gefunden habe ein was
das nicht gefunden die haben mir das geschickt und 50k gegeben um das zu bewerben das ist eine
sache die finde ich verwerflich aber sich hinzustellen und sagen jungs werbung das ist das neue mmo bla bla
bla ihr könnt ihr super toll leveln und es ist das schönste mobile mmo aller Zeiten und fertig
das ist easy sehr easy live und da weiß auch jeder das ist jetzt nicht hier irgendwie meine
persönliche wenn ich das so sagt dass das meine persönliche überzeugung ist das wird
einfach runter eingebaut und halt werbung erzählen weil man sollte es bei games was halbwegs gut ist
ganz ehrlich umso beschissener die games umso mehr kohle gibt es dafür werbung für koinmars na gut
also irgendwann ist auch mal eine grenze unterschritten also koin master werbung ist
ja schon ziemlich beknackt aber ganz ehrlich wenn einer zu mir ankommen würde und sagt max
gibt ihr 50k macht koin master werbung warum nicht aber nicht so wie die anderen koin master
werbung gemacht haben die haben ja quasi ihre persönlich die haben es ja so verkauft als wäre
es ihre persönliche überzeugung dass koin master geil ist die haben quasi versucht in ihre eigenen
das so anzusprechen die leute dass sie quasi sagen oh ja ich finde koin master ist ein tolles
spiel so nach dem motto hat er gerade mein dorf angegriffen das finde ich beknackt aber wenn
man sagt so nach dem motto dieses video ist gesponsort von irgendwie hörbuch hörbuch
plattform xy hier könnt ihr immer die neuesten hörbücher zu den aktuellen bestsellern und von
den besten sprechern ever anhören und mit dem max fps promo code kriegt ihr auch keine ahnung
zwei bücher umsonst der link ist in der beschreibung das ist dabei da ist auch ist so eigentlich das
ist das ist das ist mir morgens gedämmert also im klo gesagt da ist so eigentlich nichts dabei
das ist dass er das checkt jeder dass das werbung ist das sind keine irgendwie verwerflichen dinger
ja das ist jetzt nicht dass ich da irgendwie ja in welche casinos oder oder glücksspiel seiten
oder oder abzocke skin seiten oder so bewerbe ganz normales zeug was ich halt in den videos
platzieren will meiner meinung sollte man nichts bewerben was man nicht selbst davon überzeugt
ist ja kann man kann man so sehen aber ich bin mittlerweile zu dem schluss gekommen das dachte
ich auch immer aber ich finde es überhaupt nicht verwerflich solange man nicht den leuten quasi
verkaufen möchte dass es eben dass man das video jetzt irgendwie macht weil man so überzeugt davon
ist ja ich bekomme dafür aber vielleicht geld aber trotzdem ich hätte das video auch so gemacht
weil es ist so ein tolles produkt das finde ich beknackt aber einfach nur sagen hey das video
wird gesponsert von xy und dieser dienst da könnt ihr das und das und das machen das checkt doch
jeder und wenn es halt wenn es normale dienste sind da denke ich ist überhaupt nichts dagegen
zu sagen nix oder näher es kommt drauf an also wenn man ein ein komplettes promotion video macht
jetzt beispielsweise so ganz schrinken oder irgendwas anderes das wollen die in der regel sehen
aber es geht mir bei dieser sache auch nicht um irgendwelche komplette promotion videos sondern
um sachen die ich einfach einbauen kann in normale videos guckt euch das balino tech tips zum
beispiel an er macht das genauso er macht seine videos und dann erwähnt er in dem video mal 30
45 sekunden irgendeinen irgendeinen hardware software service anbieter und das sind ja in
der regel auch keine scam produkte oder so die er bewirbt aber weil da erwartet ja auch keine
dass er die alle persönlich kennt und unter die lupe genommen hat ja wenn das auf den ersten
blick seriös aussieht dann denke ich kann man das auch machen ich weil ich würde auch keine
casinos oder coin master oder keine ahnung skin trading seiten oder so machen also irgendwas was
das scam aussieht aber mal angenommen angenommen es kommt jetzt irgendein anbieter von energy
drinks oder von von gaming booster oder irgendwas keine ahnung ja wenn jetzt zu mir kommt sagt
max was hältst du davon willst du nicht willst du nicht ein paar mal das bei uns in die in die
videos einbauen da sehe ich da eigentlich überhaupt kein problem war mittlerweile drin wenn ich dann
sage hey das video ist gesponsert von gaming booster xy bestes gaming getränk weil keine ahnung
super viel vitamin c drinne ist und wenn ihr mehr wissen wollt dann guckt mal im link unten vorbei
da erkennt jeder sofort dass das werbung ist
das ist klipp und klar dann werbung
und das bringt halt richtig was
da wird so viel geschwätzt dass das eine stück pütter nicht mal komplett gefordert haben
verwendest du das github tool was welches
du meinst ob ich generell github verwende
genau schneeflöckchen oder schneeflöckchen sehe ich auch so nur weil man was selbst nicht
ausprobiert hat heißt es ja nicht dass es automatisch scam ist im endeffekt also
ne das hat einer hat einer gerade im chat gefragt ob ich das kenne sagt man was zum
lieb lauter ich habe es noch nie verwenden hat mich noch gerade einer im chat gefragt
aber das was ich da so lese klingt eigentlich nach einer sinnvollen lösung
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere hast du dein gesamtes youtube geld noch nicht mal angefasst
ja so gut wie nicht das einzige was ich von meinem youtube geld gemacht habe ist er ist
ich habe zwei leuten den privat kredit gegeben mit ich muss sagen das war nicht meine idee
mit fast schon unverschämt hohen zinsen das war eben nicht meine idee das haben die vorgeschlagen
gesagt leute ich habe echt schlechtes gewissen wenn ich euch die kohle für den für die geschichten
gebe ja aber die haben kohle gebraucht als weil ich die kennen ich weiß dass ich das
auch wieder krieg okay dann mache ich das weil besser als dass es rum legt
sag mal was für eine konversion benutzt du eigentlich mit der das mutterfirm ja basic
auf der steckdosenleiste was würdest du für projekte neben dem it studium empfehlen um
den lebenslauf zu finden software entwicklung technisch dann würde ich irgendwas empfehlen
also wenn du das wirklich nur dafür machst dass es gut aussieht dann würde ich irgendwas
empfehlen nicht was du geil findest also es wäre natürlich schön wenn man das verbinden
kann aber nicht nur was was du geil findest sondern irgendwas was ein bisschen wissen
ist was was bei den ganzen firmen angesagt ist zum beispiel macht irgendeine sache auf
java basis irgendwas enterprise mäßiges keine ahnung ist ein schönes enterprise mäßiges
irgendeine java basierte keine ahnung inventarverwaltung oder so und verwende dafür die tools wo du
denkst dass das enterprise technisch angesagt ist das muss nichts sinnvolles sein ja das
muss den zeigen du kannst das und es ist irgendwie auch techniken die auch verwenden weil da
muss man auch ehrlich sagen ich sag ja auch ich sag ja immer wenn mich die leute fragen
so hier auch im film was man zum einstieg fürs programmieren machen sollte da sage
ich immer mach was oder such dir was raus was du was du machen willst was du wo du schon
quasi ideen hast was du umsetzen willst oder irgendwas was dich nervt wo du selbst was
programmieren willst weil dich andere software nervt und dann sucht ihr die passenden sprachen
und technologien dafür raus wenn ich was aber wenn du mich jetzt fragst du was soll ich
programmieren dass es immer im lebenslauf gut aussieht dann muss man natürlich tools
nehmen die business mäßig etabliert sind ja und da ist natürlich gut wenn du dich
mit java auskennst wenn du mit java eds auskennst wenn du dich mit wie heißt der maven nachfolger
ich bin da nicht so drinnen was java angeht mit irgendwelchen java bild tools auskennst
mit irgendwelchen java repo geschichten auskennst das ist nicht verkehrt ich meine ich würde
im leben nicht nicht mit der mit der kneifzange oder den isolierhandschuhen angreifen and
cradle cradle mein ich glaube cradle ist ich kenne mich ja nicht so aus
java klar java ist business technisch die meistverbreiteste programmiersprache überhaupt
den ganzen business anwendung sind entweder java oder wenn es finanzzeug ist und noch
älter dann sind die koborn java ist nicht für alles blatt pack ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß es aus dem kopf nicht das was tuja convert standardmäßig mitliefern kannst
du mal nachgucken ich weiß es nicht du bist noch in der gottkategorie ich weiß wir spielen
auch gleich weiter der nico hat auch was interessantes gesagt natürlich ist es auch nicht schlecht
je nachdem für welche business sachen du was machen willst wenn du ein bisschen buzzword
bingo machst also wenn du irgendeinen bot ai programmierst und das auf docker laufen
lässt oder noch besser auf kubernetes dann nicht laufen lassen du kannst ja bloß schreiben
dass es dafür gedacht ist vollkommen egal ob das wirklich da drauf dann bei dir läuft
und wenn du dann auch wenn du da noch blockchain dabei schreibst dann ist ja alles dann flippen
sie aus es ist vollkommen egal ob kubernetes im heimnetzwerk oder hauptgruppe reibst dabei
reib dabei dass deine software optimiert ist in kubernetes zu laufen vollkommen egal was
das eigentlich jetzt genau heißen soll das ist ein schönes buzzword wo gerade viele drauf
kubernetes oder azure sach es ist es ist quasi one click deployment für kubernetes und
azure das klingt gut one one click also so easy one click deployment azure und kubernetes
dann sagen die alle alter boah ist der ist der modern azure und kubernetes da finden
das geil ja ja ne das machen das machen nicht leute die sich in der it auskennen das machen
meistens mit personal leute die sich die leute also die zuerst mal die die quasi die sachen
durch die finger in die finger kriegen waren personal leute oder irgendwelche leute die
zwar in der it sind aber dort irgendwelche management funktionen haben die von der technik
keine ahnung haben und die finden das geil wenn da blockchain drin steht kubernetes und
azure das ist das finden finden die geil weil man muss sich auch mal überlegen dass viele
große unternehmen ja gar nicht mehr so diese klassische bewerbungsgeschichte machen dass
du dich direkt bei denen bewirbst sondern die schreiben das irgendwo aus über irgendeine
zwischen firma die das quasi schon vor filtert und vorauf bereitet und die haben überhaupt
keine ahnung was da eigentlich die sache ist die kriegen bloß gesagt wir brauchen leute
mit cloud erfahrung mit kubernetes erfahrung mit ansible erfahrung mit docker erfahrung
mit sonst was und wenn es dann halt nicht da ist dann sagen wir da passt dafür nicht
du kannst bw la ziemlich gut vermeiden wenn du in die bereich geht allerdings erst wenn
du drinnen bist davor sind halt irgendwelche personaltypen meistens bei größeren leden
ja wenn du jetzt natürlich bei kleineren firmen die das noch selbst machen dann sieht
das anders aus ich finde es immer lustig wenn personalleute beziehungsweise business business
bwl leute entscheiden wollen ob jemand technisch was kann oder nicht wir achten wirklich drauf
ob leute einen anzug an haben und sowas da habe ich mir auch schon mal mit den leute
das hat doch überhaupt nichts zu sagen der typ der kennt sich doppelt so gut aus wahrscheinlich
wie alle anderen die heute den ganzen tag da hatte aber da hatte halt kein anzug an
ja und wo ist das problem
wenn du ein tila mit anzug suchst da musst du dich nicht wundern wenn du keine gescheiten
leute findest also wer wirklich sagt bei uns ist anzug pflicht da findet keine gescheiten
leute er gibt legt das aus den heißen aber nicht dass ein anzug anhalten ziehen muss
auch kein anzug an und sehen nicht aus wie der letzte kack penner der arbeit oder vielleicht
doch aus sicht von irgendwelchen rein frisur louis vuitton anzug leuten sehe ich wahrscheinlich
schon aus wie der letzte penner weil ich das nicht an habe aber ansonsten würde ich
mal eher sagen sieht sich ganz normal aus wenn man nach it leuten sucht die was taugen
mal ganz ehrlich leute geht mal auf den auf den prog auf den youtube channel und guckt
euch vorträge vom ccc und dann guckt euch mal an die leute an das sind teilweise mit
mit die besten leute die wir deutschland zu haben in manchen bereichen nicht alle aber
da sind schon gute leute dabei die sehen alle nicht business like aus ja die sehen überhaupt
nicht business style aus die typen aber die können was dementsprechend so sehen halt
leute aus die technisch was können und nicht vorne rum da auf den ersten blick halt vielleicht
so wirken im anzug als als sind es ja und der typ der in johnny hose wenn schott kam
hat die auswähler bekommen ja das ist natürlich nur so wenn die leute wenn die firmen das
selber noch machen wenn du da über irgendwelche reinen personaldinger erst mal durch muss
oder wird schwierig also fürs bewerbungsgespräch ist ein anzug schon an muss ich hatte noch
keine bewerbungsgespräche anzug an ich hatte eine ordentliche hose an und ein hemd hatte
noch nie ein anzug an also gehen tut das schon
den anzug habe ich noch aus zeiten da habe ich 65 kilo gewonnen
konnte keine ahnung 10 kilometer schwimmen und gar was weiß ich 20 kilometer rennen
oder so und war relativ fit aus der zeit ist der anzug wenn ich das heute anziehen würde
dann wäre so also ich habe die pizza fertig leute können weiter spielen einzige problem
ist ich habe noch ein brötchen jetzt geholt hier brötchen mit schokolade drauf ein bisschen
süß kram wenn ich verkehrt aber ich glaube ich spiele erstmal weiter oder kann ich noch
fünf minuten essen oder soll weiter spielen aber wir sind ja gerade nice nice am schwätzen
eigentlich essen ist wichtig naja aber es ist nicht so dass ich da von der vom fleischfalle
essen aber es ist ja gut er ist weiter
hast du erfahrung mit tätowierung in der it vor allem als er juckt das jemand keine
ahnung das bei den meisten siehst du es nicht außer sie haben t-shirt und am armen was ja
doch doch klar bei uns hat einer eins hat aber aber allein schon deswegen so lange drüber
nachdenken muss juckt das juckt das zumindest bei uns kein großartig wahrscheinlich sieht
es ein bisschen anders aus wenn du halt quasi komplett komplett auch im gesicht und so zu
bist keine ahnung wenn die leute erst mal nicht ein bisschen komisch angucken uns natürlich
irgendwie davon überzeugen dass das nicht auszusagen hat was schwierig sein kann tommy
das gibt es auch keine frage keine keine frage gibt es gibt so leute die der meinung sind
ohne anzug bist du nicht kompetent das ist aber ich bin mir nicht bei sich ob das rechtlich
überhaupt okay ist jemand heim zu schicken weil er jeans und t-shirt an hat wahrscheinlich
nicht wenn man it consulting macht ja gut it consulting hört sich ja auch nur vom namen
her so an als muss man dafür was können it consulting bedeutet erste mal erste mal ich
sag nicht immer relativ banale dinge gut verkaufen zu können dass man dann auch ein paar leute
haben muss die was können je nachdem zu was man consultet wird was anderes aber consulting
geht es ja erst mal darum dass du guten eindruck machst bei nicht techniker und guten eindruck
bei nicht techniker weil ich meine du kommst also die konsulten ja nicht so leute die sich
mit technik auskennen wenn du glück hast sitzt da mal einer dabei du kommst als altikonsulten
zum zum keine ahnung zum forstand zum chef zum sonst was und das sind natürlich leute
für die ist anzug gleich kompetenz weil sie das aus ihrer eigenen welt kennen es kennt
ja jeder meistens meistens leider nur seine eigene welt
machst du noch netzwerk videos klar aber ich hab doch erst letztens vpn video gemacht
wie kann man sich habe keine pizza ich habe zwei stück pizza gegessen früher 65 kilo
und nur ein pizza früher habe ich auch gegessen früher habe ich den ganzen tag im büro gesessen
vor dem rechner
also sollte ich mal face reveal machen habe ich mich schon überlegt da ziehe ich mir
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ziehe ich mir irgendwie ein main t-shirt an oder so
also das funktioniert bei mir ziemlich gut aber es hat frame drops
ich atme jetzt kurz das brötchen ein
glaube ich habe 35 prozent cpu auslastung oder so
habe ich immer im task manager gemacht kann man eben nicht sagen dass der ja auch so top
28 prozent schneidermission ja schneidermission wir schneiden auch weiter nach dem brötchen
doch doch wirtschaft informatiker sind auch schon gefahren
wobei du höchstwahrscheinlich mehr wirtschaft als informatik machen wirst
aber kommt auch ein bisschen auf dich an 8700 k übertaktet auf 5,1 gigahertz ich sag doch
die cpu deswegen habe ich mich voll zu aufgeregt dass es geruckelt hat das ist cpu technisch
immer noch einer der schnellsten desktop cpos die du überhaupt haben kannst also vor allem
ja razor ist nicht für jeden was
wir haben auch ein paar die vorher informatik versucht haben zu studieren
was hältst du von IT security engineers es kommt auf den oder die oder das IT security
engineer an
das ist wieder so ein so ein begriff wo wahrscheinlich jeder ein bisschen was anderes rein interpretiert
die letzten haben sie mich übelst verwirrt ich habe irgendeinen speedrun stream gesehen
und da stand oben in der ecke der name des runners da stand dann sowas drinne wie keine
ahnung max runner pro das ist ausgedachter name war der name vom runner und dahinter
haben sie in klammern das geschlecht immer reingeschrieben weil es ja mittlerweile so
ist dass du nicht mehr anhand der stimme wirklich eindeutig erkennen kannst als was jemand bezeichnet
werden möchte und das hat mich verwirrt da stand das hier drinne als geschlecht habe
ich mir gedacht was ist das ich habe es nicht kapiert ich will so keinen flame ich habe
verstehe es bloß nicht ne sorry stimmt nicht stimmt nicht es stand ich glaube ich glaube
es stand ich glaube es stand he sei drinnen hat er hat er hat er multipersönlichkeiten
oder und vor allem ich glaube es ist grammatikalisch noch überhaupt keine form erfunden worden
die man dafür verwenden kann also ich habe echt keine ahnung das hat mich hochgradig
verwirrt ja wenn da was steht bei medels immer she her drinne steht ok verstehe ich weiblich
und man sagt halt sie halt her soll man vollgesprungen aber was ist day er möchte nur genau er möchte
nur so eure durchlaucht wahrscheinlich schau dir das an wachs war das ja der typ der den
kenne ich der ist ja ganz der ist ja bei den amis ganz vorne mit dabei wenn es um solche
themen geht und was ich sagen muss es ist nicht unlogisch was er erzählt an vielen
stellen es ist vielleicht ein bisschen ja wie soll ich sagen in manchen stellen ein bisschen
zu sehr auf dem offensichtlichen rum geritten aber es ist nicht es ist nicht unlogisch es
hat schon hand und fußfaser von sich gibt wachs wenn du jetzt weitermachst kriegst du
ein tutspann warum ich habe ich verstehe bloß nicht was es heißen soll wo kam die
haben wir von von meinem auferlei tool ich kann auch kokona sagen wachs switch auf mixer
genau ninja schraut wubblers die logische konsequenz ja es ninja dann schraut dann wubblers
die alles in der gleichen liga na meco ist so gut wie keine erfahrung bis jetzt ist
das neue kott lips grafisch finde ich cool aufbauen auch aber die kampagne ist bis jetzt
ein bisschen langweilig es wubblers weil ich den account erstellt habe ich glaube sogar
vom smartphone weil ich mal irgendwas im chat schreiben wollte und ich den account nie zum
stream gedacht habe
bei mir läuft die cpu 47 prozent ingame wohlgemerkt single player kampagne warum kein name change
weil ich das jetzt schon so etabliert habe dass die leute die da wären verwirrt werden
warum es auf einmal anders heißt roxy im heimnetz gute idee kommt immer drauf an für was
muss in meinem studium zwischen vba programmierung und pyson wegen was willst du auf jeden fall
vba alter hör mal auf vba 2019
vba zwischen basic for applications kannst du excel macros programmieren den vba nicht
mehr benutzt er doch aber besser machst du es auch nicht fertig gefordert hat es nur
drei stunden gedauert weiter geht
hätte wurst wenn du das irgendwie schaffst per twitch private message zu übertragen dann
schon was gab es denn zwei stücke pizza und brötchen musik aus jetzt gucken wir mal was
das was das overwatch rebellen grill in kotter kott kampagne weiter so was jetzt angesagt
schreiber mission lautstärke passt ich habe gerade in meiner ausbildung das thema it kriptografie
echt abgefahrener schett das einzige was du dir am anfang merken muss wenn es um das
thema kriptografie beziehungsweise verschlüsselung geht ist also ein ganz wichtiger grundsatz
du musst wissen können wie ein verfahren funktioniert und es trotzdem nicht knacken
können dann ist es gut also du musst wissen wie was funktioniert und mit diesem wissen
darfst du trotzdem nicht in der lage sein was zu entlüsseln ohne dass du in schlüssel
hast ich so soll ich ok ich bin wieder alex und ich soll skopen welche road ach das da
soll ich skopen dahin got it now adjust your magnification increase your zoom alex alex
boomer gameplay naja mein ernsthaft loki das ist kein boomer gameplay das ist eindeutig
zoomer gameplay gerade oder willst du was anderes behaupten also das ist ja wohl mal
den
um doch so act ist a one story blu haus
da hinten
btf
die melone
Residenz-Sleeper-Mission
Ich seh die überhaupt nicht
Bam
Weg
Wo muss das sein?
Oh
Äh
Es lebt
Oh fuck
Boah
Was ist da los?
Man kann den Kopf mal abschießen
Oh
Jaja
Huf doch doch
Alter
Na gut
Wat
Wie kommt der da hin?
Alter
Das Game
Das
Das hat echt
Das lässt die Gegner gerne im Laufen schießen
Boah
Jetzt sind keine mehr da
Jetzt
Was soll ich eigentlich machen?
Irgendwas
Eliminaten
Wow
Easy
Kein Problem
Fuck
Der schreckt
Boah
Ich seh es nicht
Fuck
It's
Super-Kreller
Boah
Kreller
Twitch Prime
Dankeschön
Huge sub
Blue house
Alter
Huge
Huge aim
Oh oh
Boah
Okay
Was auch immer
Ich habs nicht getroffen
Aber
Ich habs überhaupt nicht gekillt
Was erzählt die mir da?
Ich war das überhaupt nicht
Ich habs überhaupt nicht getroffen
Und trotzdem ist er explodiert
Das ist echt für die Noobs
Good job Alex
Voll vorbei geschossen
Nice gemacht
OP
OP ist Spray-in-Prey-Waffe
Jawoll
Oder das?
LMG sagt
Ja
Dann nehm ich lieber ne SMG mit fast genauso viel Munition
Warte mal
Kann ich das jetzt detonaten?
Das hat er nichts gemacht oder was?
Willst du später noch Multiplayer?
Vielleicht
Mal gucken wie viel los dann ist
Fertig jetzt
Gibt es Koop?
Ja
Es gibt
Es gibt Back Ops
Koop
Koop Mission
Muss ich da mit dem E-Ax spielen
Wenn ich die Kampagne durch hab
Was?
Hier
Wie lange Spieler macht schon Singleplayer?
Keine Ahnung wie sie
Wow
Seit
Sechs
Sechzehn Uhr
Oder so
17 Uhr
Au
Sehr fair
Aber gut
Die haben gesagt
Ich soll mich hinlegen
Also leg ich mich hin
Ich hab immer
Ich hab
Ich hab vergessen
Das ist Call of Duty Kampagne
Da musst du
Exakt das machen
Was dir gesagt wird
Sonst gibt's
Gibt
Wat?
Was?
Wo?
Da
Echt?
Highway?
Wat?
Denix
Ah nein
Echt?
Oder was mit dem Wind los?
Da muss ja
Du willst um die Ecke schießen
Oh
Erst um vorn am Start
Hätte ich jetzt auch nicht so viel rumschneibern müssen
Die machen das doch eh
Jo
Hätte ich würde Schneibern auch sparen können
4 Monate
Dankeschön
Pock
900 IQ
Ah?
Soll ich das machen?
Hätte ich drauf schießen
Die Dinger sind gepanzert
Jetzt ist der Wind
Jetzt ist der Wind wieder weniger schlimm
Ja
Hier da ist der LRW kaputt würde ich sagen
Sollte ich nicht weiter auf mich zufahren
Oder mal in die Richtung schießen
Da kommt was
Rekt
Noch mehr Rekt
Oh
3 Mann Collateral
Ja das hat sich ja für die gelohnt
Mit dem LRW halb durch die Wüste fahren
Und dann auf mich zu rennen
Und wappen mit mir an
Warhorn 2019
Okay
Die KI ist absolut stundstuppe
Aber richtig dumm
Huge dumm ist die KI
Monka dumm
Wenn man an der Ecke kämpft wird man kaum getroffen
Was?
Von wo?
Wo?
Wir müssen uns überhaupt nicht bewegen
Es ist easy baut
Die kriegen ja nichts gebacken
Gehts da ey?
Mal kurz hier warten bis ich wieder gerekt bin
Von da hinten schießt man sich
Ich seh das
Du bist doch alles tot
Alles down
Adia
Adia keine Panik ist alles tot
Da
GG Pure Ownage Twitch Prime
Und Sir Hydrant
Schon 4 Monate Dankeschön für die Subs
F***
Mittlerweile ist der Chat heute ja schon bei
Was weiß ich mindestens 400 IQ
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn
Die haben die Komplette Kampagne Panik geschoben
Vor dem Gas was sie von den Russen geklaut haben
Und jetzt sprengen sie das Gas einfach so random in die Luft
Obwohl die Gegner sich übelst wegbashing lassen
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn
Alter ich hab keine Gasmaske oder hab ich eine Gasmaske
Okay
Jetzt
Alter 4 für die Gasmaske
Oder muss Gas
Scheuer
Doch
Die Gegner waren dumm
Wir hätten die einfach bashen sollen
Ja super jetzt hat er das
Ist er beknackt
Das jetzt die super Twist gewesen oder was
Ist das bescheuert
Soll ich mich bewegen
Ich muss ich muss mich bewegen okay
Jetzt wollen sie uns ein bisschen schocken
Die haben ich muss sagen in dem Setting und generell in der Idee von der Kampagne steckt schon ein gewisses Potenzial drin
Wirklich genutzt wird es nicht
Also ich denke mal dass wir jetzt Fahrer sind
Fahrer als Kind oder sowas
Die Fahrer ihr Chatpack bekommen hat
Moment wenn das Fahrer ist
Ist das Anna was neben uns gelegen hat
By the way haben wir eigentlich FPS Drops
Wir werden gerettet
Wow
Ich
Wo
war
Die Weibliste mit der Kampagne, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich eine Stunde oder so, keine Ahnung, wir waren übelst lahm.
Kommen die Russen und Wäschchen alle? War klar?
Wahrscheinlich wollen sie uns jetzt beibringen, warum Farah so stinkig auf die Russen ist.
Wir wissen doch eh schon, dass der Vater jetzt stirbt, das ist doch schon mal voll klar, oder? Würde jemand mit was anderem rechnen?
Also wer rechnet, dass der Vater überlebt? Und wer rechnet, dass der Vater jetzt gleich einen Löffel abgibt?
Er stirbt 100%, anderes geht nicht in dem Game.
Mikrolex, also bei mir ist absolut Null, bobs, war nix, 0,9.
Für die Immersion.
Das kommt mir vor wie Torbjörn, ja.
Hallo, was geht?
Oh, hide from, okay, da hätte ich selbst drauf kommen können.
Ich heide.
Wo heide ich mich?
Da heide ich mich jetzt. Man kann doch nicht mal in den Schrank.
Ich heide mich in der Dusche.
Nein, ich soll mich heiden, ich kann nicht zuschauen. Das ist Absicht, dass ich das nur höre.
Welche Difficulty ist das normal?
Das haben sie spannend inszeniert, muss ich sagen, das ist ganz cool, wobei es halt Null interaktiv ist.
Es sind Trainierende für später schon.
Someone there.
Weil jetzt jeder auch rausläuft und sagt, ja, hier bin ich.
Ich habe keine Füße.
Ich bin unsichtbar.
Ich gibt es nicht.
Ich habe ein neues Objektiv.
Ich soll den Typ jetzt bashen von hinten.
Oh, voll ins Sack.
Moment, nochmal attacken.
Eindeutig, der ist absolut high IQ.
Wieso funktioniert das schon mal nicht?
Wo ist der Mann?
Komm her, jetzt werde ich dich bashen.
Der Typ ist unglaublich dämlich.
Jetzt kommt Hadiya und basht ihn. Ich wusste es, ich wusste es, das war so klar.
Alter, jetzt übertreiben sie es aber.
Er hat aber was eingesteckt.
Das war ganz nice inszeniert.
Ich würde gerne auf die Waffe switchen, darf ich aber.
Das ist bestimmt lecker.
Das ist bestimmt lecker, jetzt in die Gasmaske reinzuschlüpsen, nachdem da so ein verschwitzter russischer Soldat fünf Tage mit rumgelaufen ist.
Der ist zu schwer, um die Waffe, die konnten den Typ killen, aber er ist zu schwer, um die Waffe unter ihm rauszuziehen.
Ernsthaft.
Wie soll ich seinen Kopf mitnehmen?
Er hat es überlebt.
Jetzt fängt gleich das Haus an zu brennen.
Wir wussten es, der Vater überlebt es nicht, das war so klar.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt ganz cool gemacht mit der Background Story, aber das Zeug vorher, das war so durchschaubar wieder.
Zum Glück ist es nur mit einer Schraube an der Tür.
Sie hat die Kraft, die Türöffnung abzubrechen, aber den russischen Soldaten mal kurz im Boden wegziehen, damit sie sich eine AK nehmen können, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Wie hat die ja übelsten Durchblick gehabt, ne?
Er ist noch der Vater gestorben und jetzt schon so absolut durchblick, wie man sich da verhält.
Freifahrt ab.
Zumindest sind die Russen mal wieder die bösen. Passt ja schon mal zu Modern Warfare an sich.
Er hat eigentlich gesagt, dass hier auf logische Details geachtet wird. Keiner. Haben sie ja offensichtlich auch nicht.
Aber eine gewisse Logik macht die Sachen eigentlich nur besser.
Letzten Zugung.
Das ist doch mal ganz hübsch gemacht.
Leute, Leute, seht ihr was das ist da drüben? Erkennt ihr was das für eine Map ist da drüben? Seht ihr das? Seht ihr die Map da drüben?
Seht ihr die Map?
Das ist Asiel Cave. Das ist die Multiplayer Map. Die schlimmste Multiplayer Map im ganzen Game.
Das weiß ich aus der Beta. Das ist, wenn das nicht die schlimmste Multiplayer Map ist, dann hat das Game komplett verloren.
Das ist Asiel Cave. Das ist eindeutig das ist Asiel Cave. Nee, da hinten ist die Höhle und da vorne ist das Dorf.
Aber man kann leider nichts mitnehmen.
Ja, das ist Asiel Cave. Eindeutig, das ist 1-2-1 die Multiplayer Map. Nur mit niedrigeren Detail Level.
Es ist nicht die schlimmste. Ich ahne Schlimmes, wenn die anderen noch schlimmer sind.
Ich sehe es gerade im Vorfeld. Das bildet schon ein bisschen Schlieren, aber das kann nicht an der Bitrate oder so liegen.
6.000 ist ziemlich gut. Das muss an den Details wie Rauch und Lensflare liegen, dass der Encoder Probleme hat.
Wir können mal was probieren. Ich sehe es ja bei mir in der Vorschau. Total verpixelt ist das nicht.
Das sieht eigentlich ganz normal aus.
Ich bin jetzt auch total verpixelt. Also ganz ehrlich, 6.700 Bitrate Encoding ist okay. Also da gibt es jetzt nichts was ich da großartig machen kann.
Ja, sieht man doch hier. 6.900 habe ich. Wir können mal was probieren.
Ich stelle das jetzt mal ein MBit hoch. Mal gucken ob das on the fly geht.
Jetzt gucken wir mal. Wir streamen jetzt mit noch mehr Bitrate. Der Standbild sieht immer gut aus.
Das kann überhaupt nicht besser sein. Das ist jetzt ja auch Standbild. Ich sehe es in der Vorschau. Das pixelt übelspannhimmel.
Warum pixelt das so? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das pixel ist beim Encoder. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung. Ich habe ja immer noch ein bisschen die Vermutung, dass es am Game liegt.
Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass es am Game liegen kann.
Wir probieren jetzt mal was. Mal gucken. Ich will nur mal gucken ob das überhaupt geht mit noch mehr Bitrate.
Das geht echt mit noch mehr Bitrate. Ich meine die Bitrate ist jetzt krass hoch.
Ich sehe jetzt das pixel mega krass im Himmel. Ich habe keine Ahnung woran das liegt. Ehrlich nicht.
Probieren wir mal was. Das pixel ist mega.
Also Leute. Kein Schimmer. Ich habe echt keine Ahnung woran das liegt. Modern Warfare ist auch das einzige Game wo das rumspackt.
Aber das ist halt bei harten Farbübergängen. Da haben alle Encoder Probleme mit. Ich könnte wetten das bei jedem der das Game streamt ist das so.
Bei harten Farbübergängen. Was mache ich da gerade?
Jetzt muss ich die ablenken oder?
Ganz gebashed.
Okay.
Fahrer hält nichts aus.
Okay Fahrer kriegt aus dem Maul.
Das pixel echt ultra. Leute ich sehe es bei mir in der Vorschau. Ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist. War das mit Game Capture auch so?
Ich stelle es mal hier weiter durchs Klo. Da ist es ja noch schlimmer.
Wir probieren mal was. Ich zeige euch mal ein Gameplay von Youtube. Ich zeige euch jetzt mal ein Video wo sich schnell bewegt das Gameplay drin ist.
Battlefield Fazit.
Ach Quatsch ihr seht das ja gar nicht. Ich habe jetzt falsche Display Capture an.
Ja da pixelte auch was. Das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Also irgendwas spackt aber OBS mit den Encoding Settings. Das ist definitiv nicht richtig.
E-Frame Intervall. Ich habe da überhaupt nichts dran eingestellt. Ich habe vorhin rumgestellt als ich auf GPU Encoding geswitcht habe.
Aber Null ist Auto. Vielleicht spackt das deswegen rum.
Also das ist definitiv nicht richtig. Das ist definitiv nicht richtig so wie das ausschaut.
Vielleicht ist das OBS auch verbackt. Soll ich mal die Version updaten?
Weil ich hatte das die ganze Zeit hier immer auf Very Fast stehen.
Okay was machen wir da für gescheite Settings?
Was kann ich denn bei Profiles und so einstellen? Das ist doch eigentlich ziemlich wurscht oder?
Ja das kann sein dass das mit Keyframe rumspackt.
Da muss ich mal gucken.
Leute ist noch jemand von ganz von Anfang an da? Am Anfang hat es nicht gepixelt. Am Anfang hatten wir plus Frametrops oder?
Am Anfang hat es nicht gepixelt aber dafür hatten wir Frametrops. Und die Frametrops sind jetzt weg.
Dann liegt das daran dass ich das irgendwie auf Default Encoding zurück gesetzt hat.
Da hatte ich garantiert irgendwas anderes eingestellt hier. Vielleicht habe ich Glück und habe in einem der letzten Streams mal zufällig meine Settings gezeigt.
Dass ich nachgucken könnte was ich hier eingestellt hatte.
Ne ne das reicht. Very Fast reicht. Das Pixel liegt definitiv irgendwo irgendwo anders.
Das liegt nicht an der Bitrate. Das liegt auch nicht an dem wie viel Zeit der Encoder bzw. CPU der Encoder dafür für einen Frame braucht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall irgendein anderes Problem.
Kann man vielleicht, wir probieren mal was aus.
Wenn ich das hier auf Simple stelle.
Start ist mal neu.
Guck mal es ist jetzt 21 Uhr. Ich könnte eh nur noch eine halbe Stunde spielen.
Ich glaube ich bastel da morgen früh mal und dann machen wir die Kampagne morgen fertig.
Schnappt ihr mal einen Bitrate Rechner?
8K
Auflösungen FPS hat mit Bildradar erstmal gar nichts zu tun.
Ich meine es sieht halt einfach beschissener aus. Umso mehr Bilder, umso mehr Pixel du durchschleusen musst, umso schlechter ist es bei der Bitrate.
Ähm, umso schlechter sieht es aus. Vergleicher Bitrate.
Aber ich glaube ich hatte schon immer Constant Bitrate.
Und den Multiplayer kann ich auch immer spielen.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich irgendwo in einem der letzten Streams meine OBS Stats gezeigt habe.
Wenn ich die gezeigt habe, dann...
Meine OBS Stats waren ja gut.
Das ist bloß das Problem, dass ich die am Anfang wegen den Frametrops umgestellt habe.
Das sagt.
Da muss ich mal suchen.
Na ja, da würde ich sagen, Leute wisst ihr was, wir spielen eigentlich morgen den Rest. Das kann nicht mal allzu lange dauern.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich irgendwie noch eine Stunde oder so spielen wir Kampagne.
Und dann spielen wir mal ein bisschen Multiplayer. Gucken wir mal was Sache ist.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns dann bis, warte kurz, bis morgen.